okay we're gonna try to start on time in
about a minute
okay this being veterans committee we
start on time uh and so I'd like to ask
representative Manion uh to lead us in
the pledge if you would
yes
we don't need a quorum for hearings
um we will need a we would need a quorum
if we to exec uh any any uh items which
we will not be doing today uh but since
you mentioned that yes we will have an
executive session a week from today in
the afternoon
okay uh hr8 and uh welcome
representative Ames the prime sponsor
glad you're here and uh
I had uh I fed about 200 messages in the
last few hours on this measure so
there's great interest in it and um
looking forward to your uh introducing
Bill thank you for being here
well good morning and thank you and uh
of course it's not surprising that
there's great interest uh whatever point
of view one has uh in this subject
particularly given what's happened
recently uh again whatever your views
may be
um so I have handed out uh
uh a couple of items one is
essentially my statement I'm going to
read some of this but I will probably
skip over some of this too and then uh
there's a I was looking for a good
uh synopsis or summary that's uh
non-partisan that presents the legal
issues the Constitutional issues that
arise after the Bruin decision last
I think it was in June
and uh so that's what this Duke Center
for firearms
law handout is
um
so diving right in
um I am here to introduce as Prime
sponsor and to speak in support of HR
Aid which is a proposed New Hampshire
house resolution asking the United
States Congress to enact legislation
regulating and banning certain
semi-automatic assault weapons and and
large capacity ammunition feeding
devices
so I think we need to begin with what's
in this resolution I think ordinarily at
least the bills that I deal with which
are tax bills that are too complicated
to read text but in this case it's very
brief so I think
I think it
is a good thing to look closely at the
text and uh there we begin with uh
so-called whereas Clauses that really
contextual statements uh putting in
context the uh the request in the
resolution and the first of these
contextual statements
uh asserts and it is an assertion that
the safety and Welfare of the people of
New Hampshire is at extreme risk due to
the absence of federal rules
setting and providing for the
enforcement of reasonable limits on the
manufacturer's sale ownership and use in
the United States of semi-automatic
assault weapons and large capacity
ammunition ignition feeding devices and
then that's followed with a second
whereas or contextual statement
that asserts again it's an assertion
that the extreme threat to the public
safety posed by insufficient Federal
Regulation of semi-automatic assault
weapons and large capacity ammunition
feed devices extends beyond the
boundaries and legal authority of any
single state
and therefore requires uniform
Nationwide laws and enforcement
and then we get to the actual resolution
that's called for
that would be
the result of enactment of this
hr8 the resolution requests
urgently
all members of Congress to work together
for the earliest possible enactment of
legislation providing for Federal
Regulation of semi-automatic assault
weapons and large capacity ammunition
ammunition feeding devices
including therein reasonable definitions
bans based on Extreme risk of harm of
certain defined
semi-automatic assault weapons and
feeding devices appropriate Legacy or
grandfathering provisions and exceptions
and sufficient funding to enable timely
and responsible Nationwide
implementation so that's the heart of
the resolution
I wanted to point out that there is now
a Bill in Congress it's a refiled but
also redrafted bill in the Senate uh
filed just I think last week
uh it was yes it was introduced on
January 23
2023 by Senator Feinstein and others
with the stated goal of protecting
communities from military-style assault
weapons it is a
126-page bill
it does a number of things and these are
in bullets it bans the sale manufacture
transfer and importation of 205
military-style assault weapons that are
named so they're named weapons there's a
list and the owners of the existing of
weapons as of the date of enactment of
this bill in the Senate as it's drafted
now may keep their existing weapons
and I'm going over to second page here
it also bans more generically any
assault weapon with the capacity to
utilize a magazine that is not a fixed
ammunition magazine and has one or more
military characteristics including a
pistol grip a forward grip a barrel
shroud a threaded barrel or a folding or
telescoping stock and again owners of
these this these weapons that meet this
definition may keep them if they had
them and had acquired them before the
date of this Senate Bill if it should be
enacted
um
it to further bands this Senate bill for
the bans magazines and other ammunition
feeding devices that hold more than 10
rounds of ammunition
which are designed to allow Shooters to
quickly fire many rounds without needing
to reload and again owners of
magazines asset the date of the bill
would be allowed to keep those
it requires a background check on any
future sale trade or gifting of an
assault weapon covered by the bill
it requires that grandfathered or Legacy
assault weapons are stored using a
secure gun storage or safety device like
a trigger lock
it prohibits the transfer of high
capacity ammunition magazines it bans
bump fire stocks and other devices that
allow semi-automatic weapons to fire at
fully automatic rates
and then it includes a bunch of exam
exemptions there's a long list so that's
why it's a multi-page so many pages are
in the Bill it exempts by name more than
2200 guns for hunting household defense
or recreational purposes
and it includes a grandfather Legacy
Clause that exempts all weapons lawfully
possessed at the date of enactment
um
I'll skip over the first statement here
just to try to save time a statement by
uh Senator Blumenthal when this uh
Senate bill was
was issued was filed it's I think it's
an excellent statement but I don't need
to read it now I'll read the Sandy Hook
promise statement this is a national
non-profit organization as you may know
that was founded and fed and is led by
several family members
whose loved ones were killed at Sandy
Hook Elementary School back in
2012. this is a statement in support of
the new Senate bill and they say assault
weapons are
military-style firearms designed to fire
multiple rounds and quick succession
killing people quickly with little
effort that's why they've been used in
our country's deadliest mass shootings
from Sandy Hook and eovaldi to tragic
shootings in recent recent days
and they go on we cannot accept another
moment of inaction in the first three
weeks of 2023 alone there have already
been 39 mass shootings including a wave
of shootings across California and in in
Louisiana just this week
sadly another school shooting also
happened in Des Moines Iowa on the heels
of a deadly weekend of mass shootings
and finally they say every minute
lawmakers fail to stop the sale of these
weapons of war children's lives are at
risk
I wanted to say a word about uh
California because they've got as you
probably know extensive uh laws
designed to prevent gun violence
and and yet they've just experienced
these mass shootings so what's going on
and this is a statement from an ABC News
article there are too many there are too
many guns in the U.S to completely
prevent gun violence in any given State
the experts that the ABC reporter was
talking to said
gun violence is continuing to affect a
large number of Californians but at much
lower rates than other states and that's
the important Point while
3449 people died from gun violence in
California in 2020 the state still has
one of the lowest gun death rates in the
country at 8.5 deaths per 100 000 people
about 37 percent lower than the national
average
according to CDC
uh you know CDC data gun homicides in
California at a rate of 3.9 per 100 000
people is much lower than Texas's rate
of 6.1 per 100 000
people and that's from every every town
apparently
and the last thing I wanted to point to
is the Constitutional law issue
um as uh I suspect you know there's uh
been a uh a major shift in the constant
our understanding of constitutional Law
related to the Second Amendment and uh
and gun law statutes that uh set
restrictions on gun laws the decision
was uh New York Rifle and epistle
association fee Bruin
it was issued in I believe June 9 2022
the primary opinion was the leading
opinion was uh justice Thomas there were
also two concurring opinions and a
descending opinion as I recall
um and uh it was not an assault weapons
ban bill it was on New York's law
relating to pistols and concealed carry
I think
but it had General language and clearly
raised new issues that have to be
addressed in thinking about any assault
weapons than the handout that I've
passed out and I've also got a link to
it here on my testimony
um
seeks to lay out the test that Bruin
calls for now to determine the
constitutionality of of legislation you
can read it for yourself I won't try to
summarize here but it's a multi-pronged
complex analysis that is that involves
diving into history and usage and uh
and uh pre-existing restrictions on guns
uh or on similar types of weapons and uh
um there's no uh there's no you can't
snap your fingers and say aha this is uh
yeah this is okay and this is not
because it's not going to be that simple
um and so we're going to just have to go
through that process as we have with so
many issues in the history of this
country and figure things out as we go
and you figure the things out by taking
a position and here I'm asking that that
we take a position and push forward this
uh resolution uh calling for a ban on
assault weapons and um and certain
magazines
and so I'm urging you to vote uh to
consider this bill this uh resolution
and uh and bring it out ought to pass
thank you
thank you representative Ames uh
questions for the prime sponsor uh
representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you came out with a
whole bunch of statistics on gun
violence like in California and all that
percentages and stuff do you have those
statistics for uh gun violence in New
Hampshire
uh not not right here I can certainly
help you get them
um I think uh well I'm not I'm not going
to has it uh particular numbers I I'd
like to get back to you on that thank
you
representative Manion
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh the Feinstein bill that
you're describing does it also uh ban
federal agencies and law enforcement
from carrying these same weapons of war
as you say it has a list of uh a number
of categories of exemptions uh including
I think
not every federal official but
appropriate Federal officials are
Exempted from this
the the if I may the I actually have it
here it's this thick
okay and somewhere in here there's a
list of these exemptions
um I'd be I got this off the internet I
can give you the okay the link I do have
a follow-up follow-up so the uh since
these keep being classified as weapons
of war do you believe that federal
agencies such as the FBI should be
operating with weapons of war within the
United States borders
well we've always uh drawn a distinction
I think in our history between civilian
life and and our law enforcement
agencies and law enforcement agencies
often do use military-style weapons
another follow-up this will be the last
one so uh are is the reasoning there
that the federal agents have more of a
right to defend themselves than the rest
of us
uh well obviously I don't know the
reasoning but I think that uh that is
not a right to defend themselves it's uh
it relates to training and uh a charge
to these agencies to protect the public
safety and uh it puts them into a
different category than a civilian
other questions for the prime sponsor
seeing none representative thank you for
your testimony and for your measure
uh we had slated an hour for this
hearing and as I mentioned earlier I had
uh I've had 200 plus uh emails on this
and so we were prepared for a full house
and a lot of pink cards and I have one
pink card
uh so far and that would be from uh
representative J.R Hall
welcome representative hole
thank you chairman members
there that's better good morning members
of the committee thank you
representative hole representing the
towns of Bo sorry I've done Barton hooks
at Allen's down in Epsom now known as
Merrimack 27.
here representing myself my constituents
as well as the members of the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition an
organization based in New Hampshire that
is dedicated to protecting the rights of
the citizens of New Hampshire in
particular our second amendment rights
um there's a lot that I could talk about
I'm going to start with our request is
that you if possible indefinitely
postpone this bill as a recommendation
not just itl
this bill didn't even deserve the paper
it was printed on
um
the former speaker made my argument for
me he talked about California a place
that has all sorts of laws he said that
this was doing a good job and yet
they're still harm the reality is
criminals don't obey the laws that we
put on the books
and because of that okay one more
additional law is only going to impact
the law-abiding citizens
one of the members asked about whether
there was an exemption for federal
agents and pointed out the FBI well the
FBI is a law enforcement agency so one
might might make the argument
that the FBI being a law enforcement
agency might need a higher capable
firearm but what about the IRS let's at
least talk about the other agencies that
happen to have the same Firearms okay
that are is in the business of
collecting tax revenue
um one of the members from the committee
asked about the tables and how New
Hampshire ranks relative to other states
I have that data I will send that data
it's on my laptop the FBI collects this
data every year I happen to have in
front of me right now the table four of
the National Crime data from 2018 and 19
because that was the quickest one I
could find on my laptop sitting in the
seat to answer the question that was
asked
murder right this is the violent crime
data violent crime data for the country
on a per 100 000 person basis is 5.0
um the Northeast is slightly better than
that the Northeast is
um hold on where's the number is
3.3 in in 2019. so in general the
Northeast is doing better
I would love to say we're the safest
state but main beat us
um Maine is down at
um
in terms of
is 1.5 and New Hampshire is sorry I did
not bring this is 2.4 so while both New
Hampshire and Maine are significantly
lower than the Northeast as a whole and
the national average
um
and why New Hampshire and Maine and
Vermont have some of the most reasonable
gun laws on the books when it comes to
allowing citizens to protect themselves
um I would argue that no one wants to go
commit a crime when they have a chance
that the person they're committing the
crime is going to respond back to them
and then let's go through the language
that may be over the top
sentence line one the people of New
Hampshire is at extreme risk
um the FBI data that I just described
shows exactly the opposite we are safer
than the rest of the nation
it then goes on to discuss the term
semi-automatic assault weapons
um
at best that's a mischaracterization
um modern rifles okay are not assault
weapons
modern rifles are what most people go
target shooting with
modern rifles allow the attachment of
Scopes and maybe bipods
so you can do long-range target shooting
um this is a mischaracterization of a
typical modern firearm
that the bill that the former member was
discussing was like 50 pages of which 40
are one particular firearm after a
number I've read the bill is literally a
40 page list of ban this one that one
this one that one all the way down but
the the characterization in the front
again speaks in very broad language
um we don't have a problem here
and the reason we don't have a problem
here is we allow our citizens to protect
themselves protect their families
heck I wish we would allow them to
protect the students in their classrooms
um
this is an unnecessary bill I would ask
that the committee IPL at a minimum
indefinite postponement if that's an
option we should contact our house clerk
to see if it is would it even be better
because at the end of the day this is
not necessary
and with that I close my testimony
thank you representative questions for
representative Hole uh representative
Massimo
thank you representative
for taking my question
um for a late person like me what's the
difference between semi-automatic and
automatic thank you for the question
that's a great question so
semi-automatic is what most people
have as a firearm most well almost all
pistols I can't think of any that are
not
um revolvers right are all
semi-automatic you pull the trigger it
discharges one round of ammo okay and
then cycles and is ready if you pull the
trigger Again full auto has been
prohibited
um in various forms over the year
starting with the National Firearms Act
forcing attacks and then subsequently in
numerous pieces of legislation at the
federal level fires one or sorry fires
more than one projectile select
firefighters three full auto continues
to fire as long as the trigger is pulled
those are not in the hands of of
citizens and they are with several
exceptions because they're so highly
regulated at the federal level and you
need a tax stamp and literally you can't
drive to a shooting range in another
state without getting authorization it's
they are you could you could they're
collectors items at this point
follow-up
um I was
sure is one of the safest states
and criminals don't know what households
have guns or they don't have guns how do
you explain that
so
um it is good that the criminals don't
know which homes have firearms and which
homes do
in general right
um we have a very high percentage of
firearm ownership in the state
I will use my town as an example
in 2017 we removed the license to carry
prior to that our Police Department
issued a summary at the end of every
year in the town report of what they did
and how many stops for for speeding and
how many home visitations and whatever
else there was I don't know 40
categories one of those categories was a
number of licenses issued so I went back
and did the math and 22 percent of my
town
had a license to carry
of of the adults that's a significant
percentage
um
I would argue that the the unknown is
what helps be the preventative to your
question of someone wanting to break
into someone's home they may not know
who's there and how that person would
respond and there is a definite
psychological side to crime and if the
person trying to commit the crime
realizes their action may cause their
own loss of life they are less likely to
go commit the crime
thank you
other questions representative Manion
so uh to start as a preface with the law
enforcement component um
the
in the summer of 2020 there were several
uh jurisdictions that told their
citizens you're on your own during the
riots do you have any statistics by
chance showing defensive use of these
weapons
thank you for the question unfortunately
I don't
um but that does bring up the point
about just letting law enforcement only
carrying firearms
I think there's a couple of high profile
news cases where there was Broward
County being the first Texas being the
more recent where law enforcement were
in fact on site prepared to defend and
then did not and
um so I the the carve outs for law
enforcement only
um I think actually do more harm than
good the bill is bad but those carve
outs make it worse
other questions
C9 I would thank you representative
thank you we do have one more pink card
um represents several hours
is in the house I do want to point out
the previous speaker referred to this as
a bill and it is not a bill it is a HR
it's a house resolution
welcome representative
touchy thank you Mr chairman
so I just wanted to start with answering
a question that was just given over here
weapons are used for defensive purposes
between two and three million times a
year
per Federal I think it's the FBI to put
those statistics out
uh also we're hearing the term military
style assault weapons AR-15s
uh if I buy a Volkswagen and I put a
Shelby Cobra style kit on it it doesn't
make it a Shelby Cobra and these modern
sporting rifles that we call AR-15s they
just look like the replicas I mean
they're a replica just like the
Volkswagen and the Shelby Cobra it's a
replica it doesn't do any more than a
Ruger 1022 22 automatic rifle which by
the way comes with a 10 shot clip and
that that weapon that is obviously used
for recreational purposes and mostly
squirrel hunting those types of things
it's the most popular selling rifle in
this country and that would be banned
per what I've heard earlier because you
can take the 10 shot clip out put a 25
shot clip in or a 50 shot clipping I
know Vermont Massachusetts recently uh
quit selling these weapons because of
the fact you can replace the 10 round
clip that it comes with
with a 25 or 50 round clip the
California the California shooter used
an illegal Weapon by California law
so we cannot legislate this problem away
the weapons will be made one way or the
other it's still legal to make weapons
at home it's always been
legal to make weapons at home in this
country
so laws didn't stop the California
shooter in Britain Australia
where weapons have been taken away from
people even during the riots
uh they were eliminating bats kitchen
knives in Britain so it started out but
first we're just taking away your
automatic weapons or your semi-automatic
weapons and then they took everything
away and that is what the big concern is
here
uh gun violence well you know we have
China kills Millions
China uses Muslim people for body parts
just like we use innocent babies here
we've killed 63 million babies in this
country
and none of them were killed with a
replica AR-15
keep that in mind
um so these are mornings modern sporting
rifles
uh these rifles any rifle by the way is
used less than one percent at a time you
can check those out those are FBI
statistics uh the real problem is repeat
criminals repeat criminals are the ones
that keep repeating and
a felon is not allowed to own a weapon
so here we go you want to solve the
problem there's your answer
uh recently a former Japanese uh Premier
recently he was recently assassinated
with a 3D printed plastic weapon
you'll never stop the problem so what
what is what is a weapon
a weapon can be me going after a smaller
guy or a woman
we have everybody you know a lot of
people carry knives I'm carrying a knife
so weapons can be anything a broken a
broken bottle
Iraq whatever so taking away weapons
from innocent people that's not the
answer I'll tell you what the answer is
we should lock up these criminals
particularly these repeat offenders
and throw the key away
thank you very much Mr Speaker
I'll take questions thank you
representative question from
representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman uh are you aware
I'm sure you are but that
the misconception about AR-15 stands for
assault rifle 15 when actually it's the
manufacturer armale ArmaLite yes that is
correct again yes it's a modern sporting
rifle it's used for recreation I have
one
it's uh it's never got itself out of the
closet and done any harm I can assure
you
it's a modern sporting rifle I I know
it's a you know AR-15 that's right the
original ARS are made by ArmaLite that
is correct
yes sir
I'm sorry representative Finney uh go
ahead thank you
um I I think for taking my my question
um
Isaac I think we're all aware that we
have
uh some you know manufacturers in this
state that that provide a lot of jobs
um if this was to pass and and the
Feinstein bill was to be signed into law
could you envision that we would lose
uh a few thousand jobs in New Hampshire
we you know we'd see closures of Sig
Sauer uh HK I think we have a uh Ruger
uh plant up here as well
um
can you envision that the actual goal
isn't only to disarm us let's put the
manufacturers out of business and that
way the only uh
you know the the rifles that are sold in
this country would be then bought from
overseas
uh absolutely the weapons would still be
purchased uh it would put a lot of
people out of work you're correct Ruger
does manufacture in the western part of
our state we have Sig Sauer and Exeter I
believe that area
and so yes Not only would we lose a lot
of jobs here we would lose a lot of jobs
across the country uh with all the
peaceful protesting and burning of
cities down over the last couple three
years uh we have seen that people have
used weapons to defend ourselves we have
seen how the minority population is
mostly at risk if they cannot defend
themselves
and we have sold in this country year
over year more weapons than we've ever
seen purchased before now this year it's
actually slowed down a little bit but
prior it's been like 20 million year
over year more weapons being sold in
this country and of course the other
side of the coin is people are always
going to manufacture them at home that's
just life it's been happening since we
founded this country long before that
follow up follow up
um to tie this all together would you
believe or agree that the second
amendment in the closet says the well uh
regulated militia is not pertaining to
regulation of laws but but the
regulation of the actual units
themselves uh as proper trained units
and that the language and the amendment
was clear enough to say that we have the
right to bear arms but is not included
in the amendment we have the right to
bear arms and those arms are not are not
clearly defined in the amendment on
purpose
yes we are we have a second amendment it
doesn't have anything to do particularly
with hunting or recreational shooting it
allows us to defend ourselves to have
weapons and if you don't have the Second
Amendment you won't have the first
amendment I mean we are the militia if
we were to be invaded by Russia China
pick a country it doesn't matter
we are the militia and that's one of the
reasons we haven't we don't have to
worry about being invaded because
there's so many weapons in this country
there's so many people
prepared to defend themselves that yes
we have the Second Amendment for that
reason when our country was young and at
risk the second amendment was there to
make sure that King George I believe it
was wasn't going to come in and take
over the country by disarming us and so
that's the Bill of Rights and that's why
we have the Second Amendment you're
correct thank you
other questions
see none thank you representative thank
you we do have a couple more pink cards
uh representative seleg is in the houses
in the lob I should say
welcome representative
sorry thank you and thank you to all of
you for being here I am representative
Lauren selig representative I represent
Durham New Hampshire as part of one of
the new new districts
um and I am here to testify in favor of
supporting these bills
um I uh in supporting this bill hb8 to
support Congress urge Congress to enact
legislation
um Banning certain types of
semi-automatic rifles these weapons were
designed for military purposes and
that's where they should remain
um in addition the language of this bill
contrary to what the previous speaker
said
specifies that no one is going to come
to your home and take your gun that's
not the goal of the bill the goal of the
bill is to stop people from buying
weapons that are designed to murder
people murder people that's their whole
purpose it's not about self-defense it's
not about hunting a deer to be honest if
you need a weapon of this kind of
capacity to kill a deer you shouldn't be
hunting you should have your eyes
checked and maybe take a hunting course
to learn how to aim
um so the goal is to prevent deaths of
millions of people we can continue to
prevent provide and use the corporations
that representative Finney was talking
about to provide military level weapons
to the military both in our country and
in places like Ukraine where they in
fact need this level of Weaponry thank
you
thank you representative questions for
uh representative gagne go ahead thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
you're talking about
the AR-15 or the M16 with a 0.223 round
as opposed to a deer rifle have you ever
seen a 30 odd six round
bullet
I have not you should check them out and
see the difference in size okay ma'am
uh I saw another hand representative
Manion go ahead
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I like that you mentioned uh
Ukraine so uh up until this Invasion uh
it was actually unlawful for people in
Ukraine the civilian population to be
armed uh so now coming with this most
recent Invasion they're scrambling to
train up their civilian population to
handle Firearms who haven't in a
generation had them so they're being
sent into a meat grinder with no
training no uh no arms of themselves do
you think that like that this is a good
outcome
your question is do I think it's a good
outcome that Russia invaded no the
country unprovoked I'll clarify that the
civilians were disarmed uh decades ago
so now that they ended up scrambling now
to arm them to fight in a war they
aren't arming civilians they are
training people to be military
professionals there have been huge
numbers if you actually look at the
facts there have been huge numbers of
organizations that have gone in military
organizations that have gone into
trained civilians to become members of
the military and at that point they are
arming them I don't believe that
civilians need high capacity weapons at
all I believe that the military does
follow up
do you believe that the uh Invasion
would have been slowed had the civilians
been properly trained ahead of time and
had arms of their own as the Russians
Advance into their territory
no I believe the invasion would have
been slowed If the previous
administration hadn't supported and
propped up and uh a government that has
been clearly misguided and believes that
they have the right to World Domination
representative toll thank you so much
for your testimony I was wondering if
you're hearing from your constituents
that they're concerned about
semi-automatic weapons and do you think
that the majority of them would support
this piece of legislation yes in fact
when I went out
um door knocking as part of my campaign
one of the people I spoke to was a
marine veteran who asked me specifically
to do whatever I could to reduce the
number of military grade weapons
available to the public he had lost his
nephew in one of the school shootings
and it was one where the student's
parents had provided him with an AR
whatever it's called I sorry I lose
track of the different high-capacity
weapons I'm not an expert on weapons
um and I know from the kids that I
talked to my children's friends that
they have grave concerns about their
ability to be safe in schools as a
result of these weapons being so easily
accessible
thank you
representative Finney thank you um I
hope you don't take my question as
insulting your intelligence but you
admitted that you don't understand you
know the differences between the weapons
and you you mentioned earlier deer
hunting
um we have a lot of people that serve in
the military that have used M16s and and
uh
m4s which is what they are you know but
they are 15 is based on
um would you believe
that there is no real uh
difference in the in the functionality
of these uh of these guns because they
are made to do the same thing
I I don't believe that now but again I'm
not an expert I'm not
trained in in uh military assault
weapons versus the different types of
rifles follow up
follow up and in saying that would you
agree then that the language that's used
in the testimony and that we've been
given and also in the language of the
resolution that it's also based on some
mischaracteriations of what these things
actually do their their functionality
and what they're made for no
other questions
CNN thank you representative
we have one more uh pink card here from
Sandra rice Hawkins of Concord who is in
support of the bill it's and again I it
is a not a bill it is a house resolution
it does say support the bill and the
pink card but it is an HR so welcome
that is very counter-intuitive
thank you
she can tell it's my first testimony of
the new session my name is Andreas
Hawkins I am the director of gun sense
New Hampshire a project of Grant State
progress we are here today in support of
hr8 which is a house resolution
um a lot of my testimony has been
covered already so I'm going to narrow
it down to why
the why is because American lives are
being taken by military style weapons on
our streets
AR-15s are the weapon of choice for most
Mass shooters from Sandy Hook to Uvalde
because of how much debt they can
inflict in such a short period of time
the following is just a partial list of
what an AR-15 style weapon was used in a
mass shooting
February 14 2018 the shooting at
Stoneman Douglas High School in Florida
which left 17 people dead
October 1st 2017 the Las Vegas Slaughter
of 58 people
November 5th 2017 the Sunderland Springs
Texas church shooting that claimed 26
lives
June 12 2016 the Pulse Nightclub
shooting in Orlando Florida that left 49
dead
December 2nd 2015 the San Bernardino
California shooting that killed 14
people
December 14 2012 the shooting at Sandy
Hook elementary school in Connecticut
that took 27 27 lives and over a decade
later those families are still waiting
for more action to prevent that tragedy
from happening to others
um I appreciated representative any
mentioning that these types of weapons
are rooted in military design I think
that's really important to know when we
say these are military-styled weapons on
our streets that was literally the
design that was created as a template
for the military and that eventually led
to the AR-15s this is just one type of
semi-automatic that we're concerned
about
in 1994 our country passed an assault
weapons ban which banned AR-15 and other
similar sign my automatic rifles after
it's banned mass shootings were down in
the decade that followed compared to the
decade before and the one after
specifically
gun massacres dropped 37 percent and gun
massacred deaths dropped 43 during that
10-year period this is real data and
those are real lives that were saved
I know that the political odds for this
are hard this is not a prescriptive bill
I think one of the resolution one of the
things that is great about hr8 it says
we recognize that this is an issue our
country is facing there are solutions
that we don't have to live like this the
kids can go to school without fear being
shot in their classrooms that families
can go to the movies without having it
shot up the grandmothers can go to the
grocery store and walk down the aisle
without being in fear we have a uniquely
American problem because we do not have
our policies in place that would prevent
these tragedies I asked this committee
to think very deeply about this bill
there are two outcomes when you have a
mass shooting
do you care
and if you care do you care enough to
act
we're asking you to act
with that I I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
thank you uh representative uh Gagney
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I agree
that all those mass shootings are
tragedies indeed
but you failed to mention the fact that
all these tragedies took place where
people could not defend themselves
they were they were victims there was
nobody there to answer when that person
went in
and did their things that's why why the
gun-free zones and the malls the gun
free zones and so-called is there a
question representative yes there is
would you believe
that had someone else been armed
was a good guy been able to act and
mitigate the tragedy thank you for the
question representative we actually have
had situations where armed individuals
have been present and these tragedies
have happened in States where people can
carry firearms and locations where they
can carry firearms in fact in one mass
shooting there is an armed individual
who ran and tackled the person they
believed to be the shooter well it
turned out they didn't tackle the person
who was the shooter they tackled the
person who had previously tackled the
shooter and thank goodness hesitated
before they pulled out their firearm
that's one widely publicized issue but
that's not what this bill is about we're
actually not talking about where people
can and cannot be armed we're talking
about high capacity weapons being on our
on our street weapons that are from a
military design that are not for any
other function then the purpose for
which it was created that is not healthy
for American lives I will tell you I'm
not gonna set I'm not going to entertain
a lot of questions about different types
of firearms because I'm not a Firearms
expert I'm a public health expert I'm a
I protect my kids and the and the kids
in my community expert I am I don't want
to live in fear and I don't think other
people should have to live in fear
either that is the issue we're talking
about here thank you
representative Kerry
you cited some statistics earlier the 37
and 47 7 43 I'm sorry could you tell me
the source of your statistics please yep
that one specifically University of
Massachusetts researcher Louis Clare
best and I can send that report to folks
along with some of the other data that's
been compiled most uh there's been
obviously a lot of time and a lot of
debate on this topic so there are a lot
of studies that show the drop in the um
uh those gun deaths before and after
that time period
thank you
other questions
uh I have a quick question if I if I may
so you cited in other speakers earlier
cited some horrific gun violence
examples uh you gave several from around
the country but not New Hampshire my so
my question is is your concern in the
concerns of the supporters of this
resolution uh based on
events outside of New Hampshire are
there any New Hampshire
incidents that you could cite that would
support these you're concerned yeah that
is an excellent question and I thank you
for our chair
um so this is a house resolution for
Congress to take action and I think
knowing about what has been happening
across the country it is why it is
important for us to push forward and
ensure that that is something that we
can rely on at the federal level also
when you have policies like this in
place from state to state it does create
a patchwork which leaves all of us more
susceptible and vulnerable to New
Hampshire specifically and this question
comes up a lot and again violence
prevention work what are the specific
examples here well I can tell you a lot
about suicide rates that's one of our
biggest issues we have here with
Firearms mass shootings we have been
lucky we've had very few incidences in
our history where we've had multiple
victims in a gun shooting but I will
tell you that we have had incidents here
we've had an incident at Concord High
um a couple decades ago we've had an
incident in a newspaper location just
this week on Monday we heard about a
credible school shooting threat where a
student was apprehended in the North
country that happened two days before
school got out these are things that
actually happen and we are lucky I think
Uvaldi would have said we've never had a
mass shooting right Newtown would have
said we've never had a mass shooting
nobody's had a mass shooting until it
happens but that's not what it's about
we shouldn't have to wait until people
lose their lives to take action
thank you very much
other questions so representative uh
Cole
um
so much for your um for your testimony I
know Granite State progress works with a
lot of parents and teachers in the state
do you feel like the majority of
teachers that you work with would be in
support of this resolution
uh that is an excellent question as well
um I do we have talked to a lot of
families and a lot of Educators who are
very concerned about gun violence
happening in our country and I think
sometimes we hear the responses about
hardening our schools or things like
that I'll tell you I'm a mother of two
young children I have a seven-year-old
and a three-year-old I don't want them
to go to school at a prison like that is
not the answer we know what the answer
it is it's making sure that people
complete background checks it's not
giving Firearms to people before that
background check has been completed it's
not having capacity weapons on our
street my children deserve to go to
school and learn and have the freedom to
learn an environment that is is where
they can explore and open I don't want
to hear about another mass shooting
where somebody spends days asking
whether or not a teacher left a door
open
do you know how many times kids open and
close doors in a school on a given day I
go up to drop off stuff for PTA and I
come back I have to go through a
intercom a lock system when I was a kid
you could just parents could walk in and
out why do we have that it's not because
of the other threats in society it's
because of gun violence that is
ridiculous and that's one minor thing
that I don't mind doing because it gives
Safety and Security to others but how
many more times are we going to continue
to to create solutions that are not the
actual solution thank you follow up
question follow up
just addressed that the majority of
teach
parents do you feel that vast majority
of the public school parents that
Granite State progress Works in
Coalition with would be supportive of
this resolution absolutely and I think
that that is not just true for the
people that I know pulling in our state
employee nationally has shown that there
is a lot of support for gun violence
prevention measures
thank you
is there another hand
um
representative pimani
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you think mental
health has placed more of a part than
the actual gun violence that's happening
here in New Hampshire
I really appreciate that question
because as a gun violence prevention
Advocate and also someone who carries
very deeply about Mental Health Systems
in our country we often hear that period
in with mass shootings I want to say
that if people have the proper care
systems that they need one that's a
really important issue but two people
have mental health challenges in
countries around the world and we they
don't have the mass shootings that our
country experiences so I would not say
that there is a direct correlation
between those two again I think it has
to do with the policies that we have on
firearms
foreign
go ahead oh yeah thank you so I was
holding this because I thought I'd be
asked about it
um I heard some of the previous speakers
asked about
um Firearms around law enforcement and I
did just want to make the point that um
if we remove some of the military-styled
weapons on our streets then the
militarization and the continued
proliferation of higher capacity weapons
among our law enforcement would also not
be as much of a need so representative
Finney I know that's an interest of
yours I would encourage you to consider
from that perspective and represent a
Manion as well thank you
thank you all right density hand over
there
representative cyber
you can turn my microphone on sorry
um is there an instance where the good
guy with the gun has not worked out
um specifically to the body armor
piercing
um ammunition oh um for the second bill
um so you know the good guy with a gun
and I know that this came up earlier I
I'm just gonna tell you briefly a short
my short entry into gun violence
prevention that I think addresses us
better than anything else we often hear
that as a pushback to take in action and
while I don't think it's particular to
um
hr8 I will say that in 1999 I was a high
school senior I was played in
um in tennis championships I was getting
ready for prom I was getting ready to
graduate and a few States over in
Colorado
we had the mass shooting at Columbine
and you know as a 17 year old student
and that was not the first shooting by
mass shooting at a school by the way
there had been one the year previous as
a 17 year old student that really rocked
me the fact that kids who were doing the
exact same thing I was doing were shot
down in the halls of their school and I
remember that Following fall while I was
at college going to a presentation by
the Brady campaign and there were folks
from the gun lobby and their folks from
gun violence prevention groups and they
were having this debate and that was one
of the main arguments people were
talking about at that time and people
were asked to cite
on both sides and I didn't hear stories
valid stories cited stories news or
stories of the good guy with a gun and
in the now and oh my gosh I'm gonna have
to do some math here you know I it has
been over 20 years and we still have
that kind of debate but we still don't
actually have a lot of hard data
examples to point to and so I just think
that that's a little bit of a red
hearing or misnomer and that doesn't
happen as much as maybe some people
would like to believe or you know when I
get if you're a carrier firearm and you
want to think about how you would
respond in that situation but the
reality is that is not often how it
plays out thank you
uh yes represent Emmanuel
after the federal assault weapons ban is
that correct they did yeah
any other questions
I would thank you so much for your time
and for taking the questions
Columbine just came up a couple times my
spouse went to Columbine High School in
Littleton Colorado I've actually visited
that that school where they have some
monuments
uh is there anyone else you would like
to speak on this measure
and say none we will close this at
exactly 10 30. this is veterans
committee and we're right on time
um
the next measure before us on the
schedule is H are
nine
and the prime sponsor for that is
representative agin whom I do not see
representative toll is in in the house
and is a co-sponsor and is going to step
up and um
and um
introduce the measure
um right
take take your time representative
thank you chairman moffatt and members
of my fellow members of the state and
federal Relations Committee for the
record my name is Amanda Elizabeth toll
and I'm here today to introduce hr9 a
resolution calling for the federal
government to now act an American
Marshall plan to rebuild economically
impoverished communities and strengthen
s infrastructure
in 1945 following the defeat of fascism
in the second world war Europe lay in
ruin
small villages and cities that stood for
centuries laid in rubble in the wake of
the most devastating war in human
history and the question of post-war
plans sat in front of the minds of all
in the United States Secretary of State
George Marshall advised president Harry
Truman that an economic recovery program
was needed for Europe after all Hitler's
rise and the Nazi domination of Europe
originated in the economic desperation
that was the Great Depression
Truman and Marshall knew that unless
Europe was put back on its feet the
forces of authoritarianism and division
could once again play on the desperation
of the population
though not so dramatically many
communities across the United States
face Dire Straits today
Midwest communities hollowed out by
years of de-industrialization rural
areas where jobs have disappeared due to
bad trade deals Coastal communities
facing harsher storms due to Rising
temperatures
fires in the west and flooding in the
Appalachian plain
and these crisises create problems there
are economic costs but also death
and this level of Despair is a direct
threat to our democracy just as we saw
in Europe pre-World War II
our political polarization today stems
from in part A sense of last call a
feeling that we have reached the end of
history in our most fundamental
institutions are incapable of fixing our
most basic problems this leads to fear
fear leads to anger and anger leads to
hate and hate leads to suffering
concerns about the economy and the
climate if unresolved may lead people to
seek out a strong man who promises to
fix all of our problems as so many
societies before us have
democracies work when people have faith
in the future people feel they can
invest their faith in a system when they
feel like they have a future an American
martial plan which will rebuild our
communities build climate infrastructure
give people good jobs and Inspire
Americans will give people this Faith
and Hope and in turn it could save our
democracy
thank you so much for hearing my
testimony
thank you representative would you be
willing to take any questions if there
are any yeah I'll take some questions
and and seeing none uh
[Laughter]
we have a question from representative
Finney thank you
to sound simple but you know I think we
should we should know our terms so so
what do you mean by by climate
infrastructure
my climate infrastructure so I mean
putting people to work with green jobs
for example good union jobs building
carbon neutral housing would be a
concrete example thank you so much for
the question rep Finney
other questions
representative Lundgren
thank you for taking my question
um
your concept
sounds like it's uh What uh president
just enacted was the build back better
uh program
so why do we even waste our time so this
is a little bit different than that this
is more like the FDR's New Deal which
put folks to work it gave them hope
during desperate times and it made it so
people who had good jobs could put back
money into the economy and now on top of
it with the climate crisis we could
actually put people to work
with green jobs so that way we're
addressing both problems simultaneously
the climate crisis and that people need
good paying jobs with Benefits thank you
so much I appreciate the question thank
you
representative gagne thank you thank you
for taking my question you spoke about
good union jobs does that mean that if
you didn't join a union you wouldn't be
able to work
I would hope thank you question for your
question rep gagne I would like to see
it doesn't say that specifically in this
HR I would hope that under the Marshall
Plan that we would Inc that are that are
federal delegation would support and
propose putting people to work with good
paying unionized jobs
follow up thank you are you aware that
this President Administration on the
first day in office
killed the Keystone Pipeline which
skilled seven thousand union jobs
so I am not here to speak to that I am
here today to speak to a Marshall Plan
similar to what the New Deal was that
puts people to work Building green
infrastructure in order to put people
back to work and help solve the climate
crisis thank you representative gagne
for the question
representative thank you I have one last
question
um I know it's not included in here
um and we can argue the merits of the
New Deal all day
um but that uh required a lot of
huge you know spending and we're still
paying on that with Social Security and
Medicare programs that are that are
insolvent currently
um how would we be funding uh the plan
here for for long-term Equity I think
those
have benefited
our economy and the United States and I
would like to see programs like that
preserved and expanded and so I think
that this is we when we invest
in
solving problems
when we invest in Social Services and
putting people to work in education we
spend less money on criminalization and
militarization
and I personally we're going to spend
the money no matter what would rather
spend money putting people to work and
green infrastructure then on
criminalization and militarization which
is what happens when we lack Social
Services
and when people don't have hope for a
good future thank you so much
representative the Marshall Plan would
you say sometimes is wonderful history
and
um so but that name has been taken uh do
you have a suggested name for this plan
other than Marshall
it says to
to do a new Marshall Plan just like we
would do an it's a new a green deal is a
version of the New Deal to meet Modern
Times And so the problems today are a
little different than they were during
the FDR Administration but the premise
is the same thank you so much
anything else for the uh co-sponsor
and not saying any thank you for
introducing the bill and for taking our
questions representative toll is I see
no pink cards and
um no other sponsors here is there
anyone else you'd like to say anything
to this measure
oh I'm sorry oh represent mastermill is
a co-sponsor and is this a practice uh
we
don't typically allow co-sponsors to ask
questions
um so yes so one of those uh represent
mess Miller is also a co-sponsor
uh yes I just want to acknowledge that
my mother just walked into the
brand new baby and like so I just am
really grateful that she's here so thank
you we are glad she's here too welcome
and seeing no other uh cards or
testimony we will terminate this hearing
uh early the next measure is slated for
11 15.
uh so uh I just heard representative
utter a prayer apparently so anyway
um we will uh recess at this time
um
thank you
so much
ah
we're gonna be late
okay it is 11 16.
and before we commence here with uh
with this measure of HR 13. uh it when
we complete this hearing um the folks in
the red team if you should know already
from a message uh the majority leader is
looking to come in and chat with us so
if you could stay here and if the folks
on The Blue Team uh don't mind going to
lunch uh enjoy and we will all be
if you uh if you would uh representative
and then this afternoon as you all know
we will be in reps hall for uh two
measures this afternoon uh starting at
1300 hours at one o'clock so it brings
us to H.R 13. representative Schmidt is
in the house welcome representative
Schmidt
thank you very much Mr chairman uh it's
a pleasure to be in front of uh state
and federal committee uh and look around
and see uh many of my friends and
colleagues of many years and also some
new faces representative Manion whom I
had not met before but I discovered that
we we and you
have a common Bond we are both former
members of the United States Marine
Corps 1956 to 1958 for me back before
most of you were born
and I wear the stripes proudly that I
got and I had on my show on my arm
but in any case when I was uh
a a young person uh going to school
um that was a day there was something
that the older ones Among Us will
remember remember called the Soviet
Union
um and uh the president back in those
days or the presidents back in those
days frequently talked about the captive
nations of Europe and so forth and how
important it was to have
self-determination
for the captive peoples
um and I haven't been educated back in
the public schools of the Midwest I was
born in Chicago Illinois in 1938 I
thought that we were
trying to promote that all around the
world
I discovered much later that it mostly
to apply to countries being dominated by
the Soviet Union and not So Much by
some areas that were under American
control and one of them and a number of
my fellow Marines back in those days
were from Puerto Rico
and so as I read history as a student in
college and so forth I became more aware
of uh of how Puerto Rico became a part
of the possessions of the United States
and became progressively more unhappy
with the fate of the people of Puerto
Rico especially if they were living in
Puerto Rico many of them of course had
come to the United States because
the economic situation Puerto Rico was
not that great and there was more
opportunity in back up in the in the
United States so uh but but I was I must
say I was especially unhappy in the
recent hurricane uh the devastated
Puerto Rico
um and and the the damage from the
hurricane in so many ways still has not
been sufficiently repaired
and
we had just a few days ago a power
outage
in here in New Hampshire in many places
my power went out for 15 or 20 minutes
some people were out for a couple of
days some people in Puerto Rico their
power is still out
still out imagine what it is like in the
year 2023 when we have all kinds of
devices in our homes that are powered by
electricity when the power goes out
they are just like paperweights they're
not doing the job that we bought them
for so to have your power out for years
means you're back in the 16 or 1700s so
I bring you today uh house resolution
13. I know you all can read so I I won't
read it to you
um but I will
cite just one set of whereas for more
than 100 years the people of Puerto Rico
have contributed greatly to the United
States and to democracy by serving with
dedication and honor in all armed
conflicts in the United States armed
forces
um the Puerto Ricans are doing right by
us uh and I think it's time for us to do
certainly right by the Puerto Ricans
um and that means in my view
self-determination
um
what the what choice they make what
course they follow is up to them
at least it should be
and I hope that this this committee will
recommend and this house will uh will
also confirm uh that in the state of New
Hampshire at least the New Hampshire
house believes that it's time for the
people of Puerto Rico to be able to say
how they want to pursue their future
self-determination
Puerto Rico
so that's why I'm hoping that that your
this committee will will affirmatively
support HR 13. I'll be happy to answer
any questions you might have
said Thank You representative let me
start with one real quick and thank you
for your testimony and for the
resolution so as I read this
um the title has to do with affirming
support for Puerto Rico
um and online 26 and 27 uh it simply
says that the and as you said
it looks as I read this it's a
declaration of support for the people in
choosing how to best govern themselves
in other words self-determination but it
specifically mentions whether by whether
by becoming a state or becoming
independent
and the Puerto Rico currently is a
commonwealth status so as I read this
um am I to understand that the intent of
the resolution is to let them have
self-determination but precluding
keeping the Commonwealth status
I think
that choice is for the people of Puerto
Rico whether they want to become a state
or they want to stay what they where
what they are right now the Commonwealth
that you were referenced Mr chairman uh
whether they want to have enter into a
compact for sovereignty in free
association with the United States or to
become an independent nation I don't
know what the right answer to that is
there is a right answer but it should be
for the people of Puerto Rico to decide
not for us to tell them in Beloved
benevolent overlordship
it's not for us it should be for them
question other questions representative
Finney thank you I just wanted to know
if they were to be incorporated as a
state
how many seats in Congress would they
pick up one or two maybe I think there
are something like four million people
in Puerto Rico
so you do the math uh we have two reps
with a million point three I would guess
they they would have
five or six reps something like that
six times six times four is twenty four
and so forth do the math I think there
are about 700 000 people now per rep in
the United States six or seven hundred
thousand so
do that six times seven is forty two so
they have about 4.2 million I think
and two senators too of course
that that what you have basic Civics
would involve two senators did I see
handle uh representative uh Judy did you
have your hand up yes uh representative
and then go first representative Judy
and then representative gagne thank you
Mr chair
I'm happy to see you
like always uh representative I would
like to know exactly what happened to uh
the economy of uh Puerto Rico
because I I visit Puerto Rico twice
but actually it's a beautiful Island
and uh everything was settled at that
time so what happened to the economy
right now
I I'm not understanding your question
Gene uh can you take your mask off so I
can hear you better no I told you
um what happened to the economy in uh in
Puerto Rico because I visit Puerto Rico
twice and I see it's a beautiful island
and uh I would like to know exactly uh
what happened to the economy
well it certainly suffered enormously
you can imagine a an economy that is
fully dependent on electric power when
an electric power goes out and stays out
in substantial portions of the of the
area
they go back to the not the Stone Age
but to go back to the 1600s because
uh they don't have they don't have
electric power so economically they
suffered greatly as well as losing some
three to three thousand people in the
hurricane so and they're still they're
still suffering
the the Reconstruction of Puerto Rico
lags considerably
um I don't think we know how the this
country can get behind its citizens when
Houston was flooded so dramatically by a
previous hurricane uh the it was
declared a disaster area by the
president and the for the the resources
of the American people were greatly
focused on getting Houston back into a
viable situation and the same way with
his awful hurricane in Florida and so
forth working diligently to try to get
them back into a decent position
condition
including economically uh and I don't we
haven't seen the same kind of uh effort
in Puerto Rico even though there are
some resources being applied
representative Gabby
thank you Mr chairman this could be a
question for you sir uh
which bill which house resolution paper
are we looking at the original bill or
the amendment okay so I brought you the
amendment
uh and every one of you has a copy of it
in for in front of you uh and there were
there were two two deficiencies in the
original resolution as uh as it landed
on your desks one of them referenced a
1917 election which I'm reliably
informed did not happen so that language
has been stricken because uh uh because
I've been told that that never happened
and this that's a misleading statement
uh and the other change was that it only
had just uh either a vote for Statehood
or becoming an independent nation but
the third one entering into line 27
entering into a compact for sovereignty
and free association with the United
States and those those are just three
possibilities but whatever whatever
choice they make it should be for them
that's that's the thrust of my house
resolution
is to have self-determination for the
people of Puerto Rico thank you
uh represent pimonte
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um have other legislatures in the
country put in similar resolutions do
you know
I believe that's the case I also believe
that the Congress is taking action in
this regard as well but I I would like
to see New Hampshire go on the record uh
in support of our fellow American
citizens in Puerto Rico
any other questions
thank you so much for your attention for
your questions and it's nice to see all
of you again even if I'm seeing somebody
for the first time
Cena thank you so much representative
Schmidt and I just a comment uh when
President Ford left office in 1977 after
uh the election he came out in in
publicly advocated for Statehood for uh
Puerto Rico in 1977
so I always remembered that
um
next up uh we have uh Sebastian Fuentes
of Thornton who asked for two minutes to
speak to this
problem
okay thank you Sebastian who is uh
waiving his two minutes or we're
yielding his two minutes to uh Carlos
Cardona who is here
representing himself Carlos is from
I'm sorry yes sir oh I just wanted to
encourage my colleagues to ask Carlos
some of the same questions that they
just asked representative Schmidt as he
is from Puerto Rico and can really speak
to this issue as well
and Carlos uh welcome
is it on okay thank you representative
thank you Representatives ladies and
gentlemen my name is Carlos Cardona I
was born in nagada Puerto Rico I
actually live in Laconia New Hampshire
I've called Laconia for the past 15
years my home I consider New Hampshire
to be my home I'm Granite Stater like
everybody else but for the past 15 years
I've also used this amazing Traditions
that we have here in New Hampshire
called the first in the nation to
advocate for my home Island archipelago
of Puerto Rico Puerto Rico is comprised
of actually many islands it's not just
one big island like people think there
are other islands with residents in it
about the size of Saint Thomas and the
Virgin Islands and I think most people
forget that because they travel to
Puerto Rico they go to San Juan they see
the Fortress and they say beautiful but
they often forget the 3 million Puerto
Ricans that live outside of the island
that oftentimes get forgotten including
in the last Administration that three
million Puerto Ricans were left out with
no paid no support
originally I should say I had to post
the original bill that had come before
you guys I support the amendment I
believe that the original Bill had
really good intentions but it had some
misinformation but I believe
representative Schmidt has put in the
work and I want to thank him personally
for honoring our people and making sure
that our voices were heard so I wanted
to say that but I also wanted to
acknowledge some of the questions that
popped up but if you have questions as I
speak I'm happy to answer those I want
to be available to you and any
experience that I may have had and I'll
just read what I have here for you sorry
a little nervous
um I also serve I should add that I
serve I'm an appointed member from
sununu on the New Hampshire Commission
on Native American Affairs I belong to
the tribe of higuajawa I am not here to
speak on their behalf but I do think
that my experience and my Heritage and
my ancestors have a lot to say on these
topics that you're discussing today and
I believe that there was a question
earlier whether other states have
proposed such bill I believe that
Florida and Texas are the only two
states that currently have some sort of
resolution uh cooking but nothing that
is actually before their state houses
but I do believe that New Hampshire is
being first in the nation and politics
being so important to this day I think
it is important that the state of New
Hampshire be first to say that they
support the Puerto Rican people in
self-determining I think it's also very
important that we as people that live in
New Hampshire including myself that we
are careful not to go down the road of
telling Puerto Ricans once more what to
do with their lives Puerto Ricans have
never had a say under citizenship they
were invaded by the an Imperial Crown of
Spain in the 1800s well 1600s into the
1800s and then of course the American
Spanish War happened Puerto Rican sided
with the United States in the island
during the Spanish-American war with the
promise and intention that Puerto Rico
would be independent that someday they
would live to their fullest potential
that potential never came that promise
never happened Puerto Rico has never had
to say to determine their future to this
day there's actually a gentile that
decides the finances of the island of
Puerto Rico so 3 million Puerto Ricans
two times and a half larger than New
Hampshire
ajanta gets to tell them how to spend
their taxes imagine if that happened
here in the state of New Hampshire
I know that we would all be protesting
there would be no question about it just
like we're Live Free or Die Puerto Rico
has a very similar motto we believe that
we should have a self-determination
that said current data and statuses do
show that Puerto Rico has been in recent
memory in favor of statehood but I still
because I am the only Puerto Rican here
in this room as far as I know I feel
that is my duty to make sure that I
represent all voices of the island
and I I consider that a huge privilege
and honor I will not take it for granted
so right now currently the island splits
25 Pro statehood 25 Sovereign but free
Alliance to the United States 25
pro-independents and 25 don't care don't
know
um so that's some of the data that has
for Puerto Rico I also want to take this
moment I wouldn't be myself if I didn't
take the time to honor the 3000 Plus
Puerto Ricans that died during Hurricane
Maria and actually I have lived I was
born during Hurricane Hugo on the island
there was no electricity my mom was
forced to give birth with no electricity
no water no medicine so imagine the
women in this committee well they would
that would be like especially if you've
had a child I was born during those very
terrible situations actually my family
had to ration food for seven months
during that hurricane just to be able to
make sure that we survive during
Hurricane Maria was 10 times worse the
Puerto the Puerto Rican people were
forced for nine months with no help no
running water no electricity I actually
happened to be one of those statistics I
lost my uncle Tio Oli LeBron LeBron
during the hurricane he actually
committed suicide because there was no
water no food no electricity there was
no help just trees flat fruit rotting in
the ground animals dying it was
literally what you would see in a
Resident Evil movie of the Apocalypse I
had received photos nine months after it
happened so you can understand I talked
to my father every single day in the
island
I went nine months without hearing from
him I had picture the worst my dad was
in the hospital for seven months and in
ICU he drank bad water and was poisoned
because of rat pissed in the water
something that antibiotics here in New
Hampshire would cure within 24 hours he
didn't have access to that so I do think
due to put to the American policy on
Puerto Rico like the Jones actor which
it was implemented in 1917.
um that is the consequences that have
happened and I do believe that those
deaths are because of inaction and
irresponsibility to the US government
that said I am living the American dream
I'm a business owner I have a family I'm
raising two children with my partner
John and Laconia I love the United
States just like all of you I consider
myself very patriotic and I want what's
best for our country just like I want
what's best for Puerto Rico so in this
case I do believe that as New Hampshire
rights or Granite Staters it is our
responsibility to speak up and stand
behind people that have been serving I
also thought that it'll be interesting
to provide you a quick little fun fact
that I didn't know I learned while
researching my own Island Lieutenant
Coronel theophilo and barswatch was the
first shot during World War One
so Puerto Ricans have been serving in
the united in the United States armed
forces since World War one and it was a
Puerto Rican that shot the first shot so
if you think about it everything that we
believe in today in our democratic
system was because one Puerto Rican was
brave enough to do the first shot and
actually there's a a little story in the
island of Puerto Rico that there was a
discussion who was going to do that
first shot and he without a second
thought said I will he was willing to
sacrifice his life for you and me
without a thought
so I believe that today is the right
time to stand up for Puerto Rico just
like they didn't have a second thought
about fighting for us we should have no
second thought for following up with a
promise that we made them
another fun fact in World War II Navy
Lieutenant Maria Rodriguez Denton born
in guanica Puerto Rico became the first
known women of Puerto Rican descent to
become a female Navy officer
you know when you think about women's
rights in this country and the pivotal
times that we're living
it was a Puerto Rican woman that was
willing once again to fight for us and
willing to call you know to answer the
call to duty
I have never served in the military and
I'm not going to pretend that I have any
courage that they have but if I was to
be just even have an ounce of the
courage that that woman had
it is today to speak before you and all
white mostly white board with the
exception of one bipart person
and tell you guys to please do not let
Puerto Rico down
I would love to answer any questions you
may have if there is any
thank you Carlos
um a quick comment and a question and
then
um thank you for offering to take
questions my my college roommate Jose
Enrique Casado is Puerto Rican I'll have
to alert him to uh watch the Youtube of
this hearing
um he was a five foot two gymnast I was
a six foot four basketball player we
were kind of an odd couple but uh we
looped together for two years uh love
the guy so my question is
um
the the prime sponsor
explained that he this resolution the
intent of it is to support the Puerto
Rican people in their choice for
self-determination and there is he
mentioned you gave some statistics of uh
percentages who lean one way or the
other so I just want to understand do
you yourself have a particular uh choice
in terms of what course the Puerto
Ricans would take or or you simply
supporting the resolution for
self-determination
I I believe myself to be a resident of
the State of New Hampshire I pay taxes
here and I don't think I have any right
to tell just as much as any of you don't
have a right to tell the people of
Puerto Rico what to do I believe that
for the past 15 years I have invested
more in the state of New Hampshire than
I have in my own Island so I don't think
that I have the right to tell Puerto
Rico how to vote just like any of us
wouldn't have a right to tell Texans
what to do or California or whatever
state I do believe in individual state
rights and I believe that Puerto Rico
should have its own self-determination
that's what I'm here for but I will tell
you Puerto Rico is very different than
the rest of the United States I think we
would be kidding ourselves if we said
that we were very much alike I think the
only thing that we really have alike is
the fact that we both courageous and
patriotic to our people but Puerto Rico
speaks a different language Puerto Rico
has a different culture and I as a higua
yawan I am concerned that by becoming a
state
part of our culture would die that could
be false that could be true I mean New
Hampshire has even though it's part of
the United States it has kept a strong
independent streak it has become as it's
capped as courage and his it's it's Live
Free or Die motto
but that has not been the case for
Hawaii for example you know Hawaii has
been an island that has suffered a lot
under statehood so my personal belief
and which is very public I have been
very public since I've lived here in the
state of New Hampshire I do believe that
the third option for Puerto Rico is the
most viable one and the best and most
responsible for the both the United
States and Puerto Rico which is a
self-sovereign state with an alliance to
the United States one of my biggest
concern and I think it's a concern to
many people especially of latinx
background is that we don't want Puerto
Rico to become another Cuba
where for example the government might
be hostile to the United States or worst
off which is my case I wouldn't want to
not ever see my homeland again or not
see my people I have 34 cousins seven
aunts and uncles my father my cousin
happens to be mayor of my hometown I
would love to see these people I see
them twice a year if Puerto Rico became
a sovereign state where the Hostile
whether there was hostility with Puerto
Rico in the United States of course that
would mean no travel for me back home
and that would be something that I would
be very painful for me to live with so
while I'm not opposed to statehood if it
became a statehood I would be a
hypocrite to be against it just because
I am here living in the states and I
take full advantage of the privilege of
being an American citizen and I wish
nothing but the best for my people so I
would support it but again I'm here
mostly to support the will of Puerto
Rico and just the hunger for them to
have a democratic system Puerto Rico
while they have elections for their
Governors and their senators and their
representatives like we do here they
have no Financial say in their economic
system their schools their
infrastructure with Peter Smith
representative Peter Schmidt alluded to
earlier about the infrastructure you
know it's collapsing because their
people have no say the person that has a
say is a person that lives here in the
United States of America and has no idea
what living like down there is and I
believe some of the representatives in
this committee have been to the island
so they can probably attest to the
infrastructure the potholes which
they're common here but they don't have
winter so keep that in mind
and you of course you know the the
outdated electricity and phone service
one of the biggest mistakes during
Hurricane Maria was the cell phone
towers came down because there were like
20 30 years old
that's going to continue to happen the
infrastructure is being mandated and
directed actually the person that was
contracted from Luma which is for the
electricity private companies from
Canada
so think that for that for a second you
imagine us hiring somebody from South
America to come and tell you guys us
here in New Hampshire how to build our
roads and how to build our electricity
for infrastructure
thank you for that and uh representative
toll and then representative Finney
testimony my question for you is
do you think
you gave an overview of some of the
unjust imperialism that has sadly
plagued the island do you think this
resolution would be a step in the right
direction towards making amends for that
unjust Imperial public policy it will be
a cost free
way to start amending our relationship
with the people of Puerto Rico I think
the people of Puerto Rico for many
generations have shown their will to be
helpful to the United States not only by
serving in Wars but in research I don't
know if you knew but Puerto Rico for the
longest time had the largest satellite
in the world that did a lot of research
for the United States and aracivo which
recently sadly enough was destroyed
because of hurricane Maria
the United States I think should have in
return said we'll rebuild the satellite
instead we said no we're not going to
but I think this is a good way to start
amending that relationship and showing
some good will and not only that I also
want to mention which I forgot there are
000 Puerto Ricans here in the state of
New Hampshire that have moved here
during since hurricane Maria
contributing to our economy that
happened because of businessmen like the
the owner of the common man who has been
recruiting people from Puerto Rico who
speak English to come here and help out
with the jobs all of you know that in
your communities I'm in Laconia I'm a
business owner I used to have 200
employees I have 50 right now
so Puerto Ricans are a great
contributors to our economy here in the
state of New Hampshire and especially to
business owners that are struggling to
hire today so this is a good way to send
them a signal saying we see you you
might not be the biggest minority
population in the state but we
appreciate and it's a cost-free one it
doesn't cost us anything except our time
thank you representative for that
question representative uh thank you I'm
not going to see you here in pretend I
know anything about Puerto Rico so I
appreciate the information
um so in saying that economically
speaking or politically I do I do agree
with you economically speaking I'm I'm
wondering if they were to be
incorporated as a state they would then
be subject to our tax structure if they
were an independent state they'd have
the opportunity to to enter in any
um economic compact they wanted with we
know with other countries do you think
it's more economically viable for them
to stay part of the United States or to
be independent to build up their own
economy on their own terms yeah I mean
that I have a couple of answers for that
and I hope you guys can be patient with
me as I translated it in my head
um
so I do think it's economic of
economically feasible but I have to be
honest if Puerto Rico became a state
tomorrow it would be the poorest state
in the nation poorer than Alabama and
Mississippi
that said that doesn't stop us from
loving Mississippi more or less I think
we see them just as part of the Union as
any other state so I don't think that's
how we should look at this but that said
to answer your question honestly would
be the poorest state in the country
Puerto Rico is experiencing currently
because of the infrastructure and the
lack of
and the exploitation from the corporate
greed the pharmaceutical industry to be
exact Puerto Rico has one of the highest
asthma rates in the world and it's
because of all the testing of pesticides
in the pharmaceutical industry on the
island and that's very well documented
there's documentaries on Netflix uh
National Geographics Etc so you can do
that research but just to give you a
little bit of feedback but right now
Puerto Ricans are taking advantage
anyways of our economic system I mean we
pay for their Medicare that we paid for
the their I mean there's a million
benefits that the only benefit that
Puerto Ricans right now don't take
advantage of is social security
um they're not entitled to that the
Supreme Court does classify Puerto
Ricans living in the island as
second-class Citizens which is something
I have a real hard time with so if I
move I'm a first class citizen like you
guys here in the United States if I move
back to the island I'm a second class
citizen according to the Supreme Court
and that is the legal classification so
you can call Puerto Rico what you want
but it's a colony it's a territory
there's nothing according to the Supreme
Court
so to answer your question I do think
that it'll be a fair Partnership if
Puerto Rico became a state because then
Puerto Rico would start paying taxes
Puerto Rico currently does not pay taxes
so it's actually not even beneficial
economically for Puerto Rico to become a
state because they would not only have
to start paying taxes but essentially
property tax too which currently Puerto
Ricans don't pay
as an indigenous person I do believe
that property taxes are an infringement
upon your right of your land but that's
a whole different subject and I would
love to partner with you guys anytime
with that subject I pay way too much
taxes
um but in regards to Puerto Rico I hope
that answers your question I do think
for me personally and I'm trying to be
fair with all Puerto Ricans because I
feel like an enormous amount of
responsibility on my shoulders now being
the only Puerto Rican in the room
I think all of the statuses offer a fair
chance I think what Puerto Ricans are
only asking for is just give us a chance
to have a democratic system which we
currently don't have you can hold an
election all you want but if it has
non-legal ban binding responsibility
then it's not a democratic system and I
think we as Americans need to do a
better job at advocating that even
within our own borders
other questions for Carlos
seeing none yes uh representative Judy
yes thank you Mr chairman uh I would
like you uh I would like to ask you if
you still eat plantain
I do
um you know at Christmas time and I'm
happy that you asked us because I would
love it to be a New Hampshire record
um there's a tradition that we have at
Christmas time you may or may not know
that tradition we eat pasteles which is
made out of plantains it's a very
traditional African cuisine that was
brought to us through slavery
and you know even though I am obviously
not in support of slavery I believe that
those tradition and cultures and gifts
that were brought over to Africa to us
are very much part of our life and
culture and it's something that is very
still well alive while it is hard to
find good plantains in the state of New
Hampshire I have seen the increase of
good food in the state of New Hampshire
increasing and being imported here to
the state and it shows another
contribution including the fact that
Laconia you know when I first moved to
Laconia there was no Spanish restaurant
we have four now today so to me that
makes me happy that I can taste my own
food right in my backyard thank you for
asking that question yes Mr chair
representative Kerry
follow-up yes do you like to see
um independent
you know like I said I my my thoughts
are I'm in favor of anything that Puerto
Rico decides and I hope that this
resolution passes because the the it
would send a strong message that New
Hampshire stands for democracy
um but my personal belief is that Puerto
Rico should be an independent nation
with Alliance to the United States and
for the several reasons that I made
earlier the fact that I would love to
visit continue to visit I would love a
relationship like we have with Aruba
Colombia
where it's almost Visa free so we're
able to travel back and forth and we
have a great relationship with those
Nations and of course we have military
pact with those Nations and we have a
great cooperation with them and I
believe that Puerto Rico will be a huge
asset to the United States especially
since
the location of the island in the
Caribbean it's close enough
it's the closest territory of the United
States to Africa it's the closest
territory of the United States to South
America it's very centrally located so I
do believe that there is a mutual uh
benefit but if Puerto Rico became a
state
I would not be disappointed and I'll be
still Joseph's celebratory because I am
part of this nation and I feel like I'm
just as American as anybody else and I'm
very proud and I'm proud of the service
that my family has contributed to this
nation and I want it to continue so if
it became a state sure but my concerns
why I would want Puerto Rico to become a
nation of its own is for cultural
reasons as an indigenous person
I do believe that there are damages that
we have done that are in repairable that
if we became a state Unfortunately they
might not be no return back especially
when it comes to language
um a lot of Puerto Ricans are relearning
their indigenous language
um it's being reconstructed and
acknowledged by many nations and it's
something that I would love to continue
to see
thank you representative G
gracias representative Kerry
so I wanted to follow up you cited some
statistics earlier and I wanted you to
recite them and the source of those
statistics the 25 statehood 25 Alliance
that yeah I mean for sites my my
references come very easily from the the
last referendum that happened in the
island there was a referendum I don't
have the exact year on top of my head
but I want to say it was 2013. but if
you Google you know the last I know this
is bad to say but if you Google the last
referendum that happened in Puerto Rico
in 2013 the majority of Puerto Ricans
did vote for Statehood but you could see
the percentages there
um there's about 25 percent for pro
stayhood 25 to some form of alliance
with the United States was Sovereign 25
you know we want independence and then
there's another 25 percent that says
um you know we just don't care we want
to survive we want to live we don't care
about politics and I think that's
something we can relate to a little bit
here in New Hampshire sure
other questions
representative uh Gagney
back in 65 I was in Puerto Rico I was in
San Juan
and we almost ran aground there in a
channel because you know the the ship
channel has been uh dynamited so the
ship could go in well we instead of
going
to the left of the red buoy which is red
right returning
he went to the right and we ended up
with doing about five feet
of water between the ship and
Abandoned Ship stuff anyway my question
my question is uh
did the Bacardi Factory in Iran Rico
Factory survive Maria
well you know I'm glad you care about
the alcohol industry in the island it's
something I definitely care about around
the holidays the Bacardi Factor did
survive I do want to add some a little
fun fact most of you guys know Bacardi
is a Puerto Rican rum but it actually it
originated in Cuba after the Communist
uprise the owners of Bacardi were giving
an ultimatum you either move or we own
you and so they said well Puerto Rico
has a similar flag similar language uh
dialect similar food similar music it's
beautiful why not so they moved to the
island so
um so that's the quick history of
Bacardi
other questions
uh
oftentimes
times of resolution
nature what I really like about this
resolution is that it doesn't seem of a
partisan nature it seems like we could
all come together around
self-determination can you speak to if
you believe that the nature of this
resolution is bipartisan and why both
Democrats and Republicans can come
together to support this
thank you so much that you brought that
because that was not even on my mind and
I should because I oftentimes see New
Hampshire as where Granite Staters will
get along
um but that's not always the case we
obviously have a political affiliation I
will tell you that a similar resolution
the Puerto Rico Act was passed before
Congress and it did have support I did
want to add for my Republican friends on
this committee that the statehood
pro-statehood movement is supported by
actually the co-chair in Puerto Rico of
Donald Trump
so the pro-statehood movement is by
Jennifer Gonzalez who's the current
commissioner representative for this for
Puerto Rico in DC she has been a strong
advocate of statehood and she actually
Donald Trump has sinned many times that
he would support it so to my Republican
friends here this is actually a
resolution that very similarly passed
before DC the differences the DC
resolution was actually legally binding
telling Puerto Rico they can have their
own referendum allowing them to have a
legally binding referendum so to my
Republican friends this is a resolution
the Republicans on the island love I
will say for the record because this I
think puts us in a friendly territory I
am a registered Democrat and I'm a very
strong Democrat so to my Democrat
friends I'm asking you to please support
this for the simple reason that is the
right thing for us to come together this
is non-partisan this is a situation that
both Republicans and Democrats in the
island want to get done and over with
um but yeah it is supported heavily by
Republicans and and I encourage you all
to see Jennifer Gonzalez speech I you
know I'm not the biggest fan of
Representative uh or commissioner
representative non-voting member of
Congress Jennifer Gonzalez um for
several reasons economic reasons uh
policies that she holds but like the
Jones act which I think it's a terrible
law that was enacted in 1917 to the
territories I think it's more
infringement on state rights
but that said we do agree and I have
spoken many times in DC in regards most
recently back in December I was in DC
speaking into this bill how we need to
Democrats I my my voice was there to
encourage Democrats to join Republicans
in this resolution so I think in this
state this is a beautiful opportunity
for all of you guys to come together
and support a resolution that one
doesn't cost us anything I know that we
love that and two the fact that it is
non-partisan I mean it supports every
voice in the island of Puerto Rico and
just so you are also aware quickly uh
the island of Puerto Rico the governor
is a Republican
uh the majority of the Senate and the
house are Republicans and this is a
resolution that they've been advocating
for for the past at least 10 years so
this is nothing new and the research is
out there you're welcome to Google it
but this is something that is very very
supportive by Republicans in the island
um even if I may not agree on some
policies with them
other questions
I see the prime sponsor just stepped out
uh Carlos thank you so much for your
time and your testimony and with that we
will
in this hearing
um we'll see everybody at I'm sorry uh
we have a hand up in the back yes yes
sir
oh yes certainly
um
yes yeah we you have you're Sebastian
for two minutes from Thornton sure
I don't know if I can follow up to what
college has said you know I just thank
you for allowing him to speak before me
sir uh for the record my name is
Sebastian Fuentes I'm the movement
politics director for uh rights in
democracy of New Hampshire and I'm a
resident of Thornton uh I'm here to ask
this community to support HR 13. I would
love for Puerto Rico to be part of the
uh the union myself but that's a
decision uh that they need to make no
hours uh former Puerto Rican House of
Representative speaker uh Carlos Mendez
Nunez said it's time to make a statement
that America is still The Shining City
on top of the hill with the admission of
Puerto Rico as our nation's 51st state
Puerto Rico as predominating Hispanic
state will bring America a renowned
sense of greatness an example of
plurality that equals greatness
if they decide to join the union that
could be the maximum expression of
recognition of Hispanic and Latino
contributions to America
United States citizens from Puerto Rico
are proudly served in all U.S Wars since
World War One historically Puerto Rico
has ranked alongside the top states
internal of capital military service 18
000 for World War One 65 000 in World
War II 48 000 in Vietnam ten thousand in
the Gulf War 25
000 between operation Operation and
during freedom and Iraqi freedom
there's a famous 60 60 50 infantry
regimen known as the borinkanesh
composed mostly of Puerto Ricans serve
as the only segregated Hispanic unit in
the Korean War
in 2016 they were awarded the
Congressional Medal of Honor as we all
know is one of the highest recognitions
of the land
there has been nine Puerto Rican Medals
of Honor
and 1 900 Puerto Ricans have died
defending this nation
now we live in New Hampshire and no
matter where we go we see the
contributions of Puerto Rican citizens
here in the state there are Educators
they're essential workers they feed our
children in schools they work at hotels
Banks hospitals
there are entertainers
there's they serve Justice and they're
also fight Injustice so we have a
Supreme Court Justice that is Puerto
Rican we got law enforcement members
here in New Hampshire they are also
Puerto Rican
and a lot of people active in New
Hampshire politics that were born on the
island
it's time for for granite Staters and
for all Americans to honor I respect the
right of self-determination to the
people of Puerto Rico
they are U.S citizens they should have
the right to choose just like you and I
have it so I encourage you all to
support HR 13. thank you so much
thank you Sebastian would you take any
questions
and representative I see you moving Mr
Fuentes I know many consider you to
citizens in the state regardless of
party if they knew about this resolution
would support you yes absolutely by all
means
other questions
thank you again for your time thank you
everybody and we'll see everyone I hope
at 1 pm in historic representative Saul
1300 hours
yes presumably the folks in Mission
Control are going to uh stop the feed at
this time uh I see Sean is in the house
thank you
I think I got time to go wash my hands
uh yeah
is the leader
okay yeah the leaders yeah never mind
foreign
products
uh
this would like to introducing those who
need to get started
will come up here in front
of us
foreign
[Music]
chair supporting State University
score
anyone who wishes to speak to
HR tenant
I see a CD print sponsor is still not
literally in the house
thank you for your measure of making for
uh speaking here thank you
well thank you for letting me speak on
it I'm sorry
um this resolution uh I think does a
good job
the case for what you see you should
have a statement
a license plate but do you see drivers
says
no taxation without representation
it really matters me that
that partnership yeah
um
powerful citizens
in fact the budget for DC is controlled
by Congress
and um
really where
there should be sense I think
I feel like the resolution makes the
pace I put all my good beliefs in the
resolution yeah
so thank you for letting me read it
we're asked the people living on the
land that would eventually
sedated as the District of Columbia
we're provided the right to vote for
representation and Congress with the
United States accomplishment
th Square events the passage of the
organic patterns of 1801 placed in the
District of Columbia through the
exclusive Authority
and abolish president's rights to vote
for members of Congress and the
president vice president of the United
States
of 2021 let's get pandem number
sorry
oh sorry I didn't skip that note first
word granted the right to go to the
president vice president
of the passage of the 23rd Amendment
Aquarius
one the U.S census European X means that
the District of Columbia's population is
approximately 689 500
. in comparable to Wyoming Vermont
Nebraska North Dakota
and whereas the residents of the
District of Columbia shared all their
responsibilities of U.S citizenship
including paperwork federal taxes that
residents in 20
shirt on schedule
juries and defend the United States
number of our courses we have very
warped since the work
yet they are denied for
you
awareness the residents of the District
of Columbia themselves have endorsed the
statement for the district attorney
of November 8th 2016
with Puerto Rico other territories of
the past
the will of the citizens of those areas
supposed to play parole
so whereas no other Democratic ancient
times the right of self-government
including participation in its National
legislature to the residents of
whereas the residents of the district
View electrical democracy quality and
citizenship enjoy very residency
where is the United States Congress
has repeatedly interfered with the
District of Columbia's limited
self-governance by an active laws that
affect DC's expenditures
unless globally raised tax revenue
including
borrowing the usage of globally raised
Revenue
the spiraling the fundamental principle
that states and local governments are
best suited to enact legislation that
represents the will
questions
whereas although the district can come
up here has passed consecutive balanced
budget since fiscal year 1997. it still
faces the possibility of being shut down
nearly every year because
they have the deliberations
over the federal budget
s whereas we see delegates
and Delaware Senator Tom Harper
introduced the in the 117th Congress H.R
51 and Senate 51
so Washington DC Administration I'm
sorry admission Act
providers that the state of
Native American citizens
um do you want me to keep going
yeah go ahead and finish sure I made it
this Mark
whereas the United Nations human rights
committee has called the United States
Congress to address the D.C lack of
political equity and the organization of
American states has declared the
disenfranchisement of DC
and now their board may be resolved that
we asked the House of Representatives of
New Hampshire support admitting them
to the um no taxation without
representation I did happen to live in
DC three different times
families involved
in government certainly in serving the
military has had a big impact on me and
my earliest memories of travel was to DC
my great aunt worked for NASA as a
secretary and to my great uncle her
husband was a limo driver for the White
House
for many decades
it's not
Washington DC being the center of
democracy of the world it is a Cathedral
of democracy
and no better place than Washington DC
to have his whole representation
and are there any questions
thank you for having me take questions
questions from the prime sponsor
to see I have a quick uh common question
uh representative my boss has been a
great deal of time in great DC
uh my question I guess is should state
house or should a standard come around
with the traffic problems be any better
say that again again
you think that that
things would have the competitive
traffic situation down there
I wish anyone who distributed emergency
notice it takes
versus driving matters
and today then ask the world's driving
jobs too
um Irish
that's why they have a great public
transportation system too
foreign
together
it would be that it's the only land
where U.S citizens live that does not
have representation
's capital
yet doesn't have true representation
like every other
aspect of the United States is just
impossible to me and it doesn't even
matter to me
beautiful
woman I think it just doesn't make any
sense to do anything
but questions
representation
thank you very much Mr chairs from
representative Timothy Orton County
District district 10 facility so I also
support the president and uh
covered uh
children
kind of the most amazing
not to repeat too much of the electro
iron
IC since
in the District of Columbia such bigger
than two of the uh took the existing
mistakes which is so that's good in
Vermont and they deserved
full representation in Congress although
although I am handed watch CBS featuring
Congress selection so sometimes that's a
duty is honored but if
big
dick facility
it's important that the program Jose
have no senators and they certainly
deserve
to deserve to pick if those they were
safe they were entitled to uh to
a state that the population and and two
senators
and uh they do they do have a delegate
one of the house rules um has full most
of the Privileges of a rep they already
so their current delegates who've been
1990s one of the most respective members
of the U.S house is Eleanor Holmes
Norton and she's uh this has even been a
committee chair in the past but she's a
very well respected member and she can
participate fully in the committee
process but she can't vote on the floor
not on legislation not even in the
leadership election which is your called
hints not a very few votes
and uh
the there's going to be uh I know
there's some criticisms I mean there's
like one Congressman last time he's
considered Congress claimed they could
be a state because they don't have an
auto dealership I don't know if that's
true or not but I mean that's not a
requirement but uh it would be obviously
the smallest state by far in size since
it's just a a medium-sized City but
um it uh I think there's a lot of value
to give you the full representation dark
a couple there are a couple of
and there are some practical issues in
the past like for example uh not to go
in too much details but not long ago
there was a
serious incident at at the U.S Capitol
and the mayor
was a hampered in her inner efforts to
respond just because the limitations
since she's not a governor she's just a
mayor and um
I guess there's some and so as a result
for example the DC National Guard they
do have a National Guard was not of
was not able it was not able to step in
as fast as they would have been if this
had to say happened
she was not able as debates in another
state so I'm sure like governor sanduno
for example if there's an incident here
could call it the National Guard uh you
know instantaneously without anybody
else's permission but
so there's a lot of practical issues
like that there's going to be and also
even after if it becomes a state
um
to be an enabling an act and that could
express some of the issues have been
used to argue against uh statehood I
mean like for example uh
they owned a D.C National airport which
is technically in Virginia they're
prisoners
are imprisoned uh in federal prisons
across the country because they don't
have a Penitentiary of their own they
I'm not sure where their water supply
comes from but it's probably outside the
district but those things
can be addressed in an enabling Act
and also if the committee an alternative
of course and I guess if and also like
uh as just repeat what said before but
relate to that is that we're the
only Democratic country probably the
only country
non-democratic or Democratic where the
uh where the capital many cities have a
federal district like we do that's not
part of a state or a province whatever
they have but this we're the only one
where they don't have full uh
representation in the in the Congress or
other National institutions so that uh
and uh so that's
it's just Justice is long overdue and
should be fixed and also point out uh
some countries
lots of countries give their Federal
have a federal district that's a
different slightly different legal
status from the other subdivisions but
um
every other country as I said they give
the residents of the federal district
the same political rights as people of
the rest of the country you know like
for example
for example Mexico
they have a separate federal district
for the city of Mexico but every every
uh it's the Constitution guarantees of
all the rights of a state and that's
true with other countries so please
please vote for this resolution and I
said taxation without representation is
a tyranny so thanks
would you take any questions
uh well sure
any questions for the representative
seeing none they will let you go thank
you our Senator Morgan
would anyone else like to speak to this
measure
uh
yes representative
my name is representative Schmidt again
I didn't find a pink card in the back so
I will sign in subsequently so
look around you
this committee has either cooperatively
or or uh in the person of the chair
deemed this in an issue of significance
sufficient significance to have you all
come here in Representatives Hall
because of the possibility that the
people of New Hampshire
would want to weigh in on this and the
committee room would be too small
you understand the significance of this
issue unfortunately
um and in terms of the citizenry either
for a lack of notification or awareness
uh is not here uh to take up your
perceived uh
importance of this issue but that
doesn't mean that it is less important
for that reason that
the bill the resolution has been read to
you
and so I won't believe be there for any
of the issues that you've already heard
and the facts but the reality is this
that DC ought to be a state
its citizens should not be denied the
new representation so I hope that you
will support the motion when of ought to
pass when it comes up thank you very
much
I'll answer any questions you might have
thank you representative any questions
and saying that I thank you for your
testimony thank you
in a pink card of course and I see
representative c as a pink card in his
going to be recognized from the other
side of Representative C welcome to the
hearing
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is Alvin C I represent Merrimack
County District 26.
I'm not taking a position on this
particular bill but I did want to
suggest that I think it's in the Puerto
Rico now jeez I'm sorry wrong bill in
the country's
best interest not to create another
state
but uh
if the district doesn't need all the
land they have it should be returned to
the state of Maryland
when the district was originally formed
it was 10 miles by 10 miles with
approximately half in Virginia and half
in Maryland when they realized they
didn't need the party in Virginia it was
returned to the state of Virginia so
there is precedence for that
and I think the best thing would be just
simply to return the land to state of
Maryland if the district doesn't need it
thank you
I'll take questions if there are any
girls have so my question to you on that
would be word this to revert the
original District of Columbia as you
pointed out included a lot of land in
Virginia Which uh went back to Virginia
what belonged to Maryland is now what is
the District of Columbia so if that
reverted to Maryland then Maryland would
pick up like one
or two Congress people correct
well that would be entirely possible
okay uh it it depends on what the
population is versus all the other
states so
but yes it's likely that Maryland would
increase
their delegation
to the Congress
other questions
seen on thank you representative C thank
you would anyone else like to speak to
this measure
and if not uh at this time we'll con uh
we'll conclude this uh hearing
we'll be in recess until 1 30 but
another seven minutes when we'll uh
commence with uh CA as you were HCR one
would fill out our famous pick card and
get that up here to the front table
we'll get you into the lineup
foreign
1331 here in state federal veterans uh
we'll call this channel to order on us
concurrent resolution one uh crime
sponsor is literally in the house
represent president Bernardi thank you
for being here and uh please uh proceed
thank you Mr chairman and committee uh
for the record my name is JD Bernardi I
represent Rockingham 36.
five pounds on the Southeast border of
New Hampshire
Kensington Hampton Falls Southampton
Newton and Plaistow I'm from Southampton
I Rise to present house concurrent
resolution one Convention of states
Article 5 establishes two paths to
create a constitutional amendment
not a constitutional convention but a
constitutional amendment
those two paths are either Congress
or a Convention of two-thirds of the
states
May propose an amendment
then three-quarters of the states in
either route are required to ratify that
Amendment before it becomes an amendment
not a chance not to redo the
Constitution but an amendment to the
Constitution
neither of these processes would be
successful if the great will of the
American people was not behind it
polls have shown an overwhelming
bipartisan support for the convention of
State subject matter
this resolution seeks a convention to
impose fiscal restraints on the on the
federal government commonly referred to
as a balanced budget amendment
limit powers and jurisdictions of the
federal government
and impose term limits on federal
officials
the common tasking has been adopted by
19 other states today
again there's overwhelming public
support
to address these issues
55 percent of Democrats 65 percent of
independent 75 percent of Republicans
when polled agree that these resolutions
need to be taken up
yet Congress does not act
why is that
it's not in their interest to limit
their financial or personal power or
time in office
this point received considerable
discussion during the Philadelphia
Convention forming our nation
the need for State Convention was
proposed initially by Charles Pinckney
at the very start of the Constitutional
Convention process
a summary of the statements of Mason and
Randolph
both representatives from Virginia
concurs
they say we're wearing short Congress
would not always be trusted to do what
is in the best interest of the country
and that when it is
when it is the practice of Congress
itself that gave rise to the need for
amendments some other body should be
made available to the people to initiate
changes to the Constitution
Federalist 51 addresses the need for
checks and balances separation of powers
but there also Madison writes if men
were Angels no government would be
necessary
he further notes
should the provision of the Constitution
as here reviewed by to be found not to
secure the government and the rights of
the states against user patients and
abuses on the part of the United States
the final Resort within the Constitution
lies in an Amendment of the Constitution
according to a process applicable by the
states
our contention is we have reached that
point we've reached the point
where we need a Convention of the states
to impose fiscal restraints on the
federal government to limit Federal
power returning it to the states and to
establish term limits for the federal
officials
these are issues rightfully to be
discussed in a convention
I'm open to any questions but as you
know chairman we have several highly
qualified candidates here including
Michael Ferris one of the co-founders of
Convention of States organization and
many others so I'll answer whatever
questions you have but
they may be better Suited
especially
questions for the crime
okay Shane on thank you representative
there are questions that will come up
about a runaway convention I'm not going
to I know some of us have that question
I'm not going to have it posed now I
know it's going to be addressed uh in a
bit uh what we're going to do here is
um typically our tradition is if we have
Sitting reps who are looking to testify
we try to get them uh up to the front
um there are also a couple people who
came a long way and have to leave early
so I'm going to get them up to the front
as well we have 20 plus folks who would
like to speak which is great and it's
great to see uh this turn out here I
would ask that when it comes your turn
to uh to speak and we're very much want
to hear everybody speak that's why we're
here uh if some of the points that you
wanted to make have been made before you
don't need to repeat them necessarily so
and I notice in the cards many of you
have only asked for one minute which is
uh which is one wonderful if you can be
that succinct and that organized
so all that said I'd like to go to Mr
Michael Ferris who's here from Virginia
now he's asked for 10 plus minutes
if we can make that 10 my 10 minus
minutes Mr Ferris but we want you to
There He Is We you came a long way and
we wanted and you know this material we
want to hear what you have to say so uh
welcome to Historic representative song
Mr chairman and members of the committee
thank you so much for holding this
wonderful meeting this great room this
is terrific when I was here before
several years ago we were downstairs in
a much smaller room this is terrific
thank you for the opportunity
I am an attorney been in practice since
1976 so that's getting uh close to 50
years I've argued two cases
constitutional cases in the Supreme
Court of the United States and I've
litigated the Article 5 issue in the
past in the early late 1970s when
Congress tried to change the deadline
for the ratification of the Equal Rights
Amendment going from seven years to ten
and a half years I represented several
legislators from the state of Washington
in a case that got Consolidated together
with a similar case in Idaho and Arizona
and worked together in the net finding
of that case was you can't change the
rules in the middle of the stream and
that was the the holding of the federal
district court it went to the Supreme
Court of the United States and the
Supreme Court made a summary ruling
because the second deadline passed and
they held basically that the era had
expired and so that the the prior
decision stances of persuasive but not
binding process
it's it's one of the more important
precedences Article Five and so I'm one
of the rare lawyers in the in the
country that is actually litigated in
researched on Article Five in addition
and this is germane to The Runaway
convention I published an article in the
Harvard Journal of Law and public policy
to definitively answer kind of the
Baseline question of whether or not the
original constitutional convention was a
runaway I mean the theory goes well it
was they were only supposed to amend the
Articles of Confederation and instead
they wrote a whole new document that's
the the Genesis of a lot of the
arguments that raised about the runaway
convention it's just simply historically
not true
the
uh as we all probably remember from our
history uh the Annapolis convention was
held uh previous to that they had been
given of the delegates and given uh
responsibility by their various States
Authority by their states to discuss
problems with Commerce we needed to have
a different mechanism for regulating
Commerce the delegates got together and
said we don't have enough authority to
solve the real problems and so they went
back to their states and asked for more
Authority and their The Authority they
asked for was to render the Federal
Constitution adequate for the exigencies
of the Union
several states started passing
resolutions calling for a convention in
May of 1787 in Philadelphia for that
purpose to render the Federal
Constitution advocate for the
existencies of the Union Six States
called for that convention named their
delegates gave their delegates their
various voting instructions and then at
that point the Articles of Confederation
Congress passed the resolution that has
the language only amend the Articles of
Confederation that's where it comes from
it's from that Congressional resolution
now when Congress the Articles of
Confederation Congress wanted to
communicate to the states and ask the
states to do something they had a
process of passing two resolutions the
substantive resolution and then they
have voted and approved official letter
of communication Congress never passed a
resolution of communication of the
resolution because it wasn't intended as
a request for the states it was like a
congressional resolution today endorsing
National pickle week or something it was
Express expressing the the beliefs of
Congress about it but it was not a
binding document we should all know that
under the Articles of Confederation the
Articles of Confederation Congress had
no residual or implied powers to do
anything they had no power to call a
convention or anything else and so after
they gave their resolution the rest of
the states continued and New Hampshire
was one of them continue and New
Hampshire told its delegates to render
the Federal Constitution adequate for
the existencies of the union and that's
what they did and this article goes into
great detail to prove that the delegates
officially obeyed their Instructions Not
only on subject matter but our own
voting process as well the delegates can
be held to be faithful New York for
example said that all three delegates
from their state that included Alexander
Hamilton and Yates won another man's
names escaping at the moment the three
of them all had to be present in voting
for New York to cast its one state one
vote vote and two of them got mad at the
way things were going they left new art
never voted again so Alexander Hamilton
never tried to cast the vote because
that would be violating the standards of
the state of New York set upon its
delegates the the rules that states give
their delegates have to be followed in
the historical precedent is absolutely
without exception
so
um the and there's a similar answer it
takes a long time to explain as to why
the ratification process was proper as
well the short answer is the 1787
Constitutional Convention proposed two
documents not the Constitution was one
and a methodology of ratification was a
second the Congress under Articles of
Confederation unanimously approved the
methodology only didn't vote on the
Constitution sentenced to the state
legislatures all 13 state legislatures
approved the new ratification process
which is the way had to be done in an
articles Confederation Congress in all
13 states had to approve any change in
process that's what happened and then it
was sent to the state ratification
conventions and and and we all know that
It ultimately got ratified so the whole
runaway convention mess is
anti-historical and frankly it's
defamatory of the Constitution of the
United States because if it was a
runaway convention then the Constitution
of the United States was illegally
adopted and I don't know why anybody
would call themselves a
constitutionalist I don't know why
anybody would swear an oath to uphold
and defend the Constitution of the
United States and contend it was
illegally adopted you are not a
constitutionalist if you think it was
illegally adopted You Are
anti-constitutionalist by definition and
so the people that are spreading these
rumors about a Runway convention do not
know the law do not know the history and
they are
putting forth propaganda of people who
have been enemies of the Constitution
for years and it's simply inappropriate
now
why do we need this convention at this
particular time the sponsor gave you
good reason but I'll just say this the
reason that George Mason and others said
that we need to give the states the
authority to amend the Constitution is
the federal government going to abuse
its power now think of I have 10 kids 29
grandkids you take over America your way
I'll take over America my way
um think of what would happen if I never
disciplined my 10 children
they would grow up not to be pretty
Rowdy and inappropriate you couldn't
trust what they were doing now for over
200 years now the parent who are the
states have never used Article 5 to
discipline The Runaway of federal power
and this convention needs to be called
to show the Congress show the federal
government there are limits here and we
have the authority to change your mind
we have the authority change your path
pattern of behavior and the subject
matters that we've given are limiting
Federal power and for example my
personal favorite is to impose a single
subject rule on Congress to not let them
pass the 1.7 trillion dollar package
bills where they throw everything in the
Under the Sun in into it and that would
not happen if you simply pass a single
subject rule what's going to come out of
this convention like this is going to be
something short concise and
commonsensical like that there might be
two or three other things but what we're
doing in this stage of the process is
setting the agenda for discussion the
agenda for discussion is fiscal
restraints term limits not just on
Congress but on all federal officials
and other limitations on federal power
it's safe
we've litigated we've done the
historical research if you have any
questions of the article that I've been
Mr chairman I'll give you my hard copy
all the the documents been posted on
your website or your link so you all
have access to it and I would be glad to
answer any questions that you have thank
you for this time Mr chairman thank you
Ms Ferris questions for the uh for Mr
Ferris
representative NASA Miller
thank you
in this article five convention the
Constitutional Convention and a
Convention of states
okay
um two of them are synonymous and
Article 5 convention in the convention
of the states are the same thing two
names are the exactly the same thing a
constitutional convention is what you
would do if you were trying to rewrite
the document entirely
and in order to do that we would
basically have to do the Revolutionary
power under the article of the
Declaration of Independence where it
says
we'll get upset with the government they
have the authority to to redo it that's
what you'd have to do to have a
constitutional convention to an
amendments convention there's an
amendance convention in in uh session
right now it's called Congress
and every day they're in session they
can propose amendments to the
Constitution the United States and so
this would be a convention where the
states pick who's there and the states
get to control the agenda not Congress
so the amendments are going to come from
one place and ultimately for the
resolution that we've proposed it
answers two questions who decides how
much power the federal government should
have should Congress decide how much
power the federal government should have
or should the states for this convention
process decide and I think this High
time that the states say we're going to
do it do it ourselves so our article 5
convention convention states exactly the
same thing the founders called it a
Convention of states and that's when
um I basically wrote the text that
you've got before you when writing that
that's why we called it that because of
the historical use by the founders
thank you
Spirits if this proposed convention were
to occur
who would be the convener or the
convening officer and where would it be
held who would determine where it would
be held
well the uh when there are 34 states
that call for a convention for the same
purpose now there are hundreds probably
about 500
current valid resolutions that call for
Convention of the states on a lot of
different topics and they don't they
don't call us and so the reason you
can't have a runaway you can't call us
to call a convention you can't change
the subject matter
uh at the convention either but the
Congress calls the convention they would
name the time they would name at least
the initial place that it meets the
convention itself at that point in time
once they convene could adjourn to
another location
and so if if for example they decide to
put it in Washington DC I don't think
that's a particularly good idea I think
that there'd be a lot of momentum for
moving to a a different location outside
the Beltway and and so but the the
states themselves would decide the rules
I I uh there are a lot of states that
are looking at passing a recommended
rules package and if enough States
commit themselves to a particular rules
package beforehand it's like the
delegate limitation acts the number of
states are passing
and we're working on a complete rules
package our organization has sponsored
the Article 5 compendium that's all the
log if you want a full compendium all
along the subject we have it available
for you and
we're working on a package of rules to
make it happen but in the meantime
probably the Mason's rules of
legislative practice that would be in
control
thank you other questions
representative Kerry
I just want clarification for the record
who are you recording
I represent
ative
pre-precisely Convention of States
action is the full name of the
organization
and once again you said this earlier for
those that are watching
um on the Internet or we'll watch later
you just gave us your organization is
there a website or you you repeat where
you said that information
the organization is Convention of States
cos action.org is that right
or conventionofstates.org
um thank you I I
I founded it but I've gone gone for six
years I was the president CEO of
Alliance defending freedom for the last
six years the largest conservative legal
organization in the world and so but I
retired from being CEO I could actually
be a lawyer again uh so
other questions
I thank you for uh traveling here for
your testimony thank you Mr chairman and
Rebecca uh and Rebecca a few for the for
our Clerk's sake could uh properly say
your last name before you begin your
testimony
thank you
Rebecca giamberessi
g-i-a-m-b-a-r-r-e-s-i
I'm a resident of Salem New Hampshire
and I am grateful
for this opportunity to present my
testimony to this assembly in support of
hcr1
it is my deep conviction that America is
now at a Crossroads from which there
could well be no return
we find ourselves once again living
under a tyrannical central government
not unlike the one we threw off during
the revolution
now is the time to reclaim our power as
free and Sovereign citizens
we as Citizens at the time of our
founding created our federal government
we created this body for the purpose of
serving our several sovereign states by
providing a National Defense in making
laws for the common good
instead
we find ourselves burdened by heavy
taxes in innumerable regulations many of
which do not serve the common good
often our tax money is spent to
Institute initiatives which go against
our deeply held beliefs and our natural
rights to free speech and self-defense
are being threatened
for these and many other reasons we
citizens working through our state
legislators
need to rein in the federal government
by proposing amendments to our original
Constitution for this purpose we don't
want to change our constitution we love
our Constitution and I gave the same
example is Mr Ferris so I won't repeat
it
New Hampshire has an opportunity to
become the 20th State to call for an
article 5 Convention of states for the
purpose of taking our sovereignty back
as free American citizens
it is not our goal to change our
constitution but to see that the
original structure of our government
which is proposed therein is reinstated
and preserved for future Generations
thank you
thank you Rebecca quest uh would you
take
would you like to take any questions or
if there were any
see no questions uh thank you so much
okay we have one more um
uh testifier I'd like to get up front
then we'll go right to a few reps
legislators who'd like to speak and that
would be uh Samuel fieldman Sam Samuel
representing wolf pack that's p-a-c wolf
pack
uh thank you my name is Samuel Feldman
I'm National Council for Wolf Pack I'm
testifying neutral on this resolution
today but I that's fine because I have
an expertise in the Article 5 convention
process what I'm passing out to you
right now is the same thing that I gave
you last week when I testified on a
different Bill I'm not going to talk
about that in my testimony but I want
you to have that available as a quick
reference guide for the plethora of
misinformation that I'm sure you will
hear about some of the views of the
founders and other Scholars
um you can refer to the quotes that are
often misquoted in great detail and in
context there with links to the original
sources
um Mr Ferris gave a very good background
on the theoretical
um reasons why we know that an article 5
convention can be limited and that is
important but the main thing that I want
to talk to you about today are the
practical tools that allow for that
enforcement to to uh be in effect and
the reason why we know that we can trust
the process to ensure that will happen
um the the way the founders wrote the
Constitution uh they created a system of
checks and balances and a distribution
of power between states and the state
and federal government and different
bodies and that creates what I call a
safety net around the Article 5
convention process not every protection
is written as specifically into Article
5 as an explicit protection instead
they're written into the nature of how
the government itself Works how Article
5 Works how the entire process works and
the four main bodies that have some
ability and some authority to provide
for that safety net are the courts the
the Congress the delegates and the
states and I want to tell you right up
front I don't trust the courts and I
don't trust the Congress and I don't
trust the delegates and I don't trust
the states what I trust is that Network
that safety net of all of those working
together in contention because it only
takes one of them to enforce the
limitations over the others to disagree
with the others in order to prevent the
process from leading to an amendment on
another issue and that's why when I said
to you last week 100 percent of
peer-reviewed Scholars agree that
there's no way a new limited Article 5
convention call like the one before you
today could possibly lead to an
amendment on another issue there is an
enormous body of legal research on each
of these different protections uh that
that explains how the the process can be
limited and why we know that
um that the enforcement mechanisms can
and will remain in place so first for
the the courts
um they're the courts have have checks
and balances over several other parts of
the process
um there are a number of different types
of conventions under the U.S
Constitution and under the states and
all of them have uh well each one of
them is unique they all have some
bearing on understanding how other types
of conventions work and Florida as a
state happens to have a State Convention
that is very analogous to the article
Cloud convention process every 20 years
they have a convention that's limited
specifically to budgetary issues under
their constitution the convention meets
only to propose amendments which then
get sent on to the states uh in 2008
that convention met and they proposed
some amendments that the delegates
believed were within their powers but
some other people did not agree and they
sued in the case was called Ford B
Browning the state supreme court in
Florida agreed that some of the
amendments were fine and could be sent
on to ratification other amendments I
were outside of the scope and they
enforced the delegate limitation rules
that were in place in this analogous
convention in Florida and did not allow
those to be sent on for ratification
there are also ways that the that the
court system has uh powered over the
checks that Congress has or has checks
over the power Congress has in place
um
the there's uh cases such as palabi
McCormick which show the Congress able
to use the declaratory judgment act to
make it as if Congress acted in a
situation where Congress has refused to
do its ministerial duty of calling for a
convention
um and uh in in policy McCormick it was
a different Duty obviously it was a duty
to see a member of Congress and pay him
his salary they could not make Congress
act but in that case they made it as if
Congress had done what they were
supposed to do and therefore the clerk
of Congress had to pay representative
Powell his salary uh by virtue of that
act
um there there are also the case that I
mentioned last week which was just in
2020 unanimous by the Supreme Court see
if all of you Washington which enforced
delegate limitation uh procedures those
procedures in that particular case it
was in reference to the um to the
convention to the uh electoral college
but that same exact provision was copied
virtually verbatim from delegate
limitation instructions from Article 5
ratification convention in in New Mexico
from 1933 and that com uh that concept
came originally from uh
Baskin I want to make sure I'm saying
possible in sorry I mispronounced it
last time and I appreciate
representative Kerry correcting me on
that
um it came from from Concepts that were
there as well as in numerous other
states uh the the Congress has its role
to play as well Congress has given the
authority both to call the convention
upon receiving of the sufficient number
of applications and we've seen Congress
despite having hundreds of applications
has not exercised a call and that is
because presumably depending on who you
ask uh they don't if for those who
believe that different calls cannot be
counted together as I do uh that's
because they've not had 34 on any one
subject matter for those who believe
that different calls can be countered
together in some ways then that's
because Congress
has not done its Duty
um and if you are in that ladder Camp
which I am not uh then a new article 5
convention call on a different subject
matter is irrelevant because the duty
has already been triggered so which are
whichever way you go and whichever Camp
you agree with whether you agree with me
or not on that issue
um either way a new article 5 convention
call could not trigger a convention that
could lead to an amendment on any other
subject uh Congress also has the power
to regulate the convention process there
have been numerous bills introduced in
Congress over the years it's past the
Senate unanimously twice I'm going to
talk in more detail next week when I
come back to talk about regulations
about Senator Chuck Schumer and
President Biden's views they've
expressed on those kinds of regulations
they were both in support of it as were
many on the on the other side of the
aisle as well
um
and I those regulations like I said past
the Senate unanimously twice they were
uncontroversial supported by the
American Bar Association
um the ability to regulate this process
is generally pretty well recognized uh
Congress also has the ability to send um
the the amendment on to the states and
there's limitations over that process
it's also a process that has been tried
and true and well well known and you
heard testimony about that already today
about how that works and what the
limitations are on it and court cases
that have been litigated over that
process there's quite a few that have
been litigated over that process uh then
there's the delegates I'm gonna I'm not
going to talk much about delegates the
moment because I'm going to go into more
detail on that next week when we talk
about delegate limitation statute
um but there are protections over the
delegates that we will get into into
detail on then and then finally there's
yourselves there's the states
um you have the role first to change uh
things about the country about the way
the Constitution Works through the
amendment process through the power that
was given to you as co-equal sovereigns
the states and the federal government
together both have equal power to amend
the Constitution
um and both have equal power to propose
uh amendments that are limited to
whatever subject matter you want to
limit your authority to do
um
you also have the the power to ratify
anything that comes from a convention
just as you have the power to ratify
anything that comes from uh from
Congress just as Congress couldn't
propose something and then change the
ratification procedure they have two
things in Congress they have the
amendment by two-thirds and then a
simple majority to propose the method of
ratification the method of ratification
is limited to two options either the
state legislatures or state conventions
ratify they only have those two options
they can't propose something else the
convention is limited by the exact same
provision in the Constitution to only
those two options and nothing else and
as you heard earlier today uh nothing
about the 1787 Convention contradicts
any of that indeed this provision was in
place at that point it's a different
type of convention so you have the
ability there to uh to yourselves ratify
anything that comes out of uh out of the
convention and it needs to meet a very
high bar of three quarters of the states
think about two-thirds of the states
call for convention limited to one
subject matter you then need four other
states
in that did not call for a convention on
that issue of the remaining 16 a quarter
of the other states that didn't even
call for this issue to say you know what
you guys did something so great that not
only does every state that called for
the convention agree so to form more uh
so 25 of the others and if just one
brand just one house in 13 different
states do not want to see it passed they
can block it because you need 38 States
in order to ratify and without having to
take any questions thank you famous
field another questions for Mr fieldman
representative Kerry
so I'm trying to understand process if
we go through this process of the
convention of states can the federal
government then revert what has been
done by the convention of states
um in in what way
like not send it on the same way they
are
just been the only body that has created
amendments to the Constitution sure uh
the they would have the same authority
to us to propose an amendment as they
always have historically what's happened
is that when they've seen Article 5
convention calls get very close they've
benched to the will of people we've seen
that with the Bill of Rights which
Alexander Hamilton and John Jay called
for the use of this process for the Bill
of Rights we've seen that with the 17th
Amendment we've seen that with uh other
actions in Congress but furthermore
anything that Congress proposes has the
same limitations as things that are
proposed by the states it cannot go it
cannot be ratified unless 38 States
agree to it so if the states use this
process to get an amendment to the
Constitution and Congress comes along
and proposes changing it back the states
can simply say no
other questions
seeing thank you Mr fieldman for coming
here to testify this uh is by the way is
being streamed it will be on YouTube so
it's a potential nice civics lesson for
those who uh want to understand this
better we have three reps three
legislators and if I missed anybody in
the pile I apologize
um we'll go there's one who is four one
who was against and one was four we'll
uh go in that order representative
Finney asked for one minute to speak for
the measure
foreign
good afternoon fellow committee members
I am Brandon Finney from Stratford nine
which is Rochester Ward 6. uh I come
before you as a co-sponsor of the bill
to uh to present you a few points that I
think are poignant and a little more
ethereal and not as a technical
so I want to to reiterate that the
purpose of convolving of calling a
convention is to affirm states rights
which we've heard about uh we as a free
and individual sovereign state have the
right to you know to govern ourselves
outside our federal Authority
it is important to maintain our checks
on power we also have the right to tell
the federal government that they're
being tyrannical and they need to be
reigned in and one way to do that
is to amend our Constitution and to go
through the the process that the
founders had enough foresight into to
realize that in future Generations we're
going to have societal political
and Technical evolution in our societies
and that we'll need to update
what the Constitution covers as we
progress as a society
the convention is specifically uh
designed to be limited in specific
topics
so the the you know the the fear that of
the runaway convention which we've heard
about it's it's more of a buzzword now
than anything else really has no value
we're meeting it's not possible
um
we need to have fundamental changes
to protect our future Generations
from the the uh the the scope and power
of the federal government
and to do that is is to specifically
rein in the corporatism and plutocracy
that's invaded our modern society as
we've allowed corporations to speak more
for us than the individual and the
individuals the smallest minority in our
society that's not uh you know kid
ourselves about that it's not groups
it's individuals and as an individual we
have the right to be protected uh
from that tyrannical power State you
know Federal
or other individuals
our natural rights are not at risk again
the Bill of Rights is protected it's not
going anywhere it cannot be changed it
is fundamental
and this is specifically talking about
what the role of federal government is
in our society in our economy and our
personal lives
we want to stem
political apathy and extremism in
society by making the political process
more inclusive not just to other groups
and individuals but as the right of all
citizens to be involved in their
government I mean we can look around the
room and see everybody that's involved
here that cares about the Integrity of
our future and our and and today and
today we have serious problems we are 32
trillion dollars in debt that is an
unfathomable amount of money that will
never be paid that could possibly
collapse our entire economic system and
the reason that is happening is because
we've allowed our our federal government
to be so involved and intertwined with
private institutions that can funnel all
of our Congressional campaigns that
pretty much takes
the policy out of it and uh uh excuse me
and replaces it with corporate power we
are not a corporation we are a
government of the people and we need to
change that we need to
tell our federal government that they do
not have power over us that we are a
free and sovereign individual State and
we will maintain that through the
convention process uh I will yield any
technical questions to The Experts I
think of your time and your patience
[Applause]
thank you rep representative Finney a
co-sponsor uh speaking against the
measure uh representative Timothy Horgan
is asked for up to five minutes
um thank you very much Mr chair
can you hear me
so I'm representative Timothy Horrigan
I'm also from Stratford County but from
District 10 which is the town of Durham
and uh some of my I submitted these
written remarks actually a week ago at
the same time as the hearing for HV 269
which is about uh
a delegate limitation bill so my
testimony and I submitted testimony of
that bill too although I was unable to
attend in person
and uh it's about half the sponsors of
the delegate limitation Bill HP 269 are
also sponsors of this one and
actually that feels somewhat 269
somewhat different from another bill
you're going to be hearing next week but
you can worry about that one next week
when that one comes so
anyway I shared the basic concern of the
HB 269 sponsors um which is Article Five
Constitutional Convention can easily
turn into a runaway convention and
they're preferred solution was to impose
an unworkable and set of rules on our
state's convention delegates although
that particular bill is like one that's
passed many many times this house but so
my preferred Solutions are one not to
have an article five convention in the
first place
and number two to refuse to ratify any
amendments produced by such a convention
although I suppose I would be willing to
make an exception if it was a good
Amendment
it only takes 13 out of 50 states to
block a constitutional amendment
uh line 14 hcr1 as you know specifies
we're applying to Congress
so if this convention ever happened so I
have to pursuant to an enabling Act
passed by Congress and uh which means
we'll have to send the number of
delegates they allow us to send we have
to choose them the way they tell us to
send it and
etc etc the rights and responsibilities
will be basically whatever's
convents its own rules uh states that
can be outlined in the enabling act and
then obviously fleshed out by the
convention itself and their
responsibilities
are going to be basically much the same
as those enjoyed by members of Congress
and at state level by us you know the
New Hampshire house
and actually something I
didn't mention in my which maybe I
should have worked in my written
testimonial though it's pretty long
already is that those rights of
responsibilities also have the roots in
English common law so and it's similar
to other
other parliaments in in other countries
but especially in English common law the
parliament uh
governs itself it sets its own rules
um
and it has the right you know you can't
be punished merely for voting the wrong
way when a measure comes to the floor
for example just like us we're free to
press either the
red or green buttoned
um it's not a crime to press the wrong
button although I do see Revenant shirt
lift here and I was one of the shirt
with 189 so some people decided 189 of
us Revenue shared living Andre together
voted the wrong way on a bill and we
were accused of crying but could you
speaker please speak to the measure well
I was speaking the measure Okay so
yeah the uh so if a when there's a
convention it's going to be a
it's going to be operate much the same
way the Congress already does only and
uh there's anyway to get back to the
three specified topics two of them are
so vague it's going to guarantee a
runaway convention and I don't really
know why
this is not going to be a popular state
in this room but I don't really know why
it's under necessary the federal
government is already under fiscal
constraints I mean so far as that term
is any meeting at all then the power and
jurisdiction the federal government
already is limited I mean maybe it
should be more limited I don't
necessarily like everything the federal
government does but it's it's limited
the third item it's a valid topic for
Constitutional Convention I'll actually
admit that but
I personally oppose it and I think the
majority of the American people reject
that idea every election cycle when the
Democratic re-elect Congress persons and
Senators you've been serving for a long
time more than whatever
12 years is kind of the standard for
these term limited amendments but
there's
members of Congress have been reelected
and serving for many many years and
they're not any better or worse than the
ones that have been serving a short time
and uh also by the same token long time
members can do often lose their
re-election bids I mean it happens less
often in Congress to the chair of
Mandarin than it does here we had a
number of members were lost their
re-election bids for example here in
Congo here in New Hampshire
in fact I came within four boats and
losing my primary but that's a subject
for a whole nother committee
finally I disagree and this can be even
more popular with the basic rationale
for convention
our federal government's far from
perfect in fact I'd say it's a
I'd say it's not that great at all but
it's not totally out of control it's not
out of control it's it's operating maybe
just barely if it's operating from the
bounds the United States Constitution
and it is pretty much
doing what uh
the Congress is pretty much doing what
they think the people want them to do
they may be wrong in lots of cases and
I've spent lots of 15 years life in
state government I love all three
branches of my state government but
the federal government is in most cases
more Progressive more responsive less
oppressive than state governments New
Hampshire we're a small state with
regressive tax system and our state
budget is going to be totally dependent
on federal dollars as we're going to
find out the hard way uh on Valentine's
Day when we get to do budget so
and uh and although we deal with this uh
we do have this rather wonderful and
wacky State Legislature that's different
those a lot of other states but even
here a lot of the legislation we
consider is much more restrictive than
anything that the Congress is
considering as for the federal debt
I agree 31.5 trillion it's a lot of
money and it's going up it sounds
crushing
but actually our population is 330
million and that does indeed divide out
to a hundred thousand dollars per person
which
that's a that's pretty scary although
actually I think our country probably
does have more than a hundred thousand
dollars per person worth of debt it's
not distributed very equally but I'm
sure if sake
President Putin somehow managed to buy
up all her debt we could probably break
over piggy bank would the speaker uh I
was speaking to yes so the I think the
rationale for the debt um it's we don't
need extraordinary measure like an
article 5 convention to address it and
there's another 7.4 oh there's another
seven trillion of that 35 which is just
money to federal agent when the federal
agency owes to another like because
they're revenues and their expenditures
toys match up just like we have
yeah
um
is that a member of the committee is
facing the point of order
thank you yes
is we need to talk about the bill at
hand
please well obviously if that finger
upset events twice if you could try to
be succinct and speak directly to the
measure uh representative would you turn
that uh well the red light up so we can
hear better and yes go ahead and
continue please
and both the pros to the procedure and
then I'm also arguing further that it's
not maybe
that the it's not this is not
necessarily a good solution to the
province or setting to what we're facing
us so there's a
anyway so all that debt so there's like
that uh 24 trillion of that is the money
supply and you know the FED does
sometimes lower the money supply but
obviously it's impossible to get the
money supplied down to zero in fact it's
better to have
better to have a adequate money supply
than an inadequate one so and the rates
are pretty low the US government is
actually having no trouble and of course
that's maybe one of the reasons why the
debt keeps Rising they're having no
trouble selling those debt instruments
the corporate secret you know prefers
buying those
um thank you what is your point of order
can the speaker conclude
um
we're getting way off topic I think I'm
again
I believe I'm on topic and actually uh
all right at this time you don't need to
move along does anyone in the committee
have any questions for the speaker
anyway I urge you to vote no on this um
uh I apprecially knowing this resolution
and
actually I got to the end though at one
point I pointed out the USA is that
we're actually a net creditor the rest
of the world like 14 trillion you know I
mean the global economy is not great but
I don't think this I don't think such
historical High convention is going to
be helpful at all so thank you I'd be
happy to take any questions are there
any questions for the representative
seeing on thank you for your testimony
next up I would like to go to one of the
co-sponsors representative Burnham is
representative Burnham in the house yes
she is
speaking uh up to five minutes for for
the measure
thank you representative
I thought I saw it on earlier thank you
Mr chair
representative Claudine Burnham from
Stratford County District 2.
so I recently
um there's been a little object lesson I
recently completed a homeschool civics
class for my high school senior daughter
she is um
my fourth youngest out of
my daughters that I've homeschooled and
I've had the privilege to teach them
our wonderful Constitution and how our
country operates
that was a little off cup I'm going to
go back to what I'm going to say here
because I I might share a little bit
something personal at the end so
the book this book here is kept simple
for this simplified reader and just like
this book Article 5 of the United States
Constitution simply gives the
opportunity for not only our elected
officials for making amendments to the
U.S Constitution but it also gives
opportunity to the people to have a
voice should the people decide that
their elected representatives Duties are
not fulfilled
how would American people know if their
elected officials
were in trouble
or if the American government was
hijacked
how could the people reign in and out of
control spending overreaching
nonpartisan career laddering
money making government officials
how much of what we see in our
governments today is what
I just mentioned complete abuse from
many of our elected officials
how can the American people help
Article 5 brings back the voice of the
people
it is not easy for We the People to make
a move to amending the Constitution
indeed it takes a lot of unification
in an unified Nation
the process is arduous
the effort is great for the people and
then after all that is said and done
after all two-thirds of the state's
legislatures must be willing
to call a convention
many who are opposed to hcr1 have
nicknamed the convention of States a
runaway convention
I say we are at a precipice of a runaway
government
ready to be sold to the highest bidder
in the world economic forum
I support hcr1
keep it simple
let New Hampshire's people speak
and now I share something personal
I am
first born generation in my family I
grew up in a Polish household some of
you may know my story
my both my grandparents were in Poland
when World War II broke out
my grandmother at the age of 15
one of 15 siblings
her and her oldest brother
were taken from their home in the middle
of the night after second attempts being
hiding in their home
from the Germans we would think yes
wrong that second time when I asked my
grandmother who was at the door
she said the Polish army with the German
army
they were successful the second time and
took her to Warsaw she saw Hitler she
saw Stalin she didn't know who they were
she was 15 years old
I have a 17 year old daughter
I can't imagine what she must have
thought
she was lined up in a closed down school
like cattle
physically being checked out if she was
strong enough
to handle attack of bread and a small
container of water where she traveled a
week on a train
to a farm and for seven years
she
was a slave labor milking cows all day
every day no days off
my grandfather very similar nine years
old
parents weren't able to take care of him
father had died
he's had to live in a barn in a local
Farm
to shovel manure all day so he can get
something to eat by the end of the day
and by the time he was 12 he enlisted in
the Polish Army that's where his story
ends for me
because he cannot share anymore
we are down the slippery slope already
if we don't speak
then who will
thank you
[Applause]
thank you representative
okay next I'm looking for representative
Potenza uh is is he or she I'm sorry she
is in the house she's here
from Rochester it asked for two minutes
and welcome
representative Potenza
yes I do and I would point out that we
have a tradition in the house where we
try to we do try to refrain from from um
uh signals or Applause or that type of
thing I just needed to pass that on uh
thank you representative
thank you very much
um my name's um representative Potenza
I'm Kelly patenza I'm from Stratford
District 19 in Rochester I fully support
as I'm a co-sponsor of the bill
um hcr1
I was going to say a lot of things today
and I changed my my tune because we had
of course you know Michael Farris here
which was amazing and he can answer all
of these
um constitutional questions and really
some of it is just um it's a lot of fear
and why are we living in this place
where we're basing everything on fear
and fear controls so
Article 5 was made for such a time as
this
the fathering fathers just didn't give
us you know hey just focus on these
articles they knew they knew that at
some point in time that we would reach
where we are today
we really no longer have a government
that is
about we the people
um there's not really a runaway
convention we don't have to worry about
that that's been disproven like I said
by multiple Scholars we actually have a
runaway government
so taxation without representation
everything that's going on right now
trillions of dollars in spending
that's not what I voted for
you know we are
we are about who decides right not what
is decided that's what freedom is all
about so securing freedom to be
self-governing to be able to make
decisions that align with what we
believe
um and what you believe uh without
someone trying to mandate or impose
beliefs or decisions on you
that's how our founding fathers decided
this this is why they had this option
Convention of states is really where
I've gotten so much of my information I
feel very blessed to have wonderful
people that have educated me and I'm not
a scholar on this at all
um but this article five it's truly it's
this kind of unifying
non-partisan freedom-loving movement for
Liberty that is really centrally aligned
with what like I said our founding
fathers fought so hard to give us
Article 5 of The Constitution
um was given us so we can ensure that
we're able to continue to be the land of
the free and the home of the brave
and so the only question really left to
ask all of you is are you brave enough
to help us fight for the freedom to keep
it
thank you
thank you representative is there any
and it looks like we're not going to be
taking questions here at this time are
there any other legislators here sitting
legislators that we've missed
and not seeing any uh I'd like to ask
the honorable Jim rubin's uh former
multi-term state senator here in Concord
from Aetna uh welcome back uh Senator
Rubens
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for taking the time to hear
this bill
so I'm going to focus on first of all a
little background I've been involved in
the uh what's I'm calling the amending
movement I'm for all of the above
and so I'm a background former District
Five state senator representative
Hanover Lebanon New London area
uh former chair of the New Hampshire GOP
platform committee so I've dig into
ideas
I was a GOP Primary candidate for the
U.S Senate in 2014 2016 have experienced
the election process from various levels
I'm a member of the uh of an informal
group a Steering group that works
together with all the amending
organizations
that is
trying to keep in touch with one another
trying to mobilize together I'm a board
member for American promise
americanpromise.net which is the
nation's leading group focused on a
congressionally drafted amendment to
allow Congress and the states to limit
campaign money
and I'm a volunteer backer of the
Wolfpack state-led Article 5 process
also focused on seeking limits to uh
allowable limits to uh to campaign money
so I'm involved in I've been very very
involved in this movement at many levels
for about 10 years so I'm just going to
speak to two things one I'm going to
speak to all members of the committee
about the runaway process and
protections against that the the alleged
asserted
hypothesized or runaway convention to
put you at ease on that and secondly I'm
going to speak uh just to maybe the
Democrats on the committee here uh you
know on another topic but and I won't
repeat uh protections against Runway
except there are basically nine of them
nine levels of protection against a
runaway convention that would digress
from the application that you see here
in hcr1 the the document you see is a
very very very brief it describes what
delegates can do what they can talk
about what they can propose at the
convention so the hypothesized runaway
convention is a process where somehow we
get something different than what is
described in the bill you see right here
in HCR one so protection number one
you've probably already heard about this
the U.S Department of Justice opinion of
1979 which clearly opines that a
convention can limit itself to the
subjects named as you see here in hcr1
that's Protection One
protection two is a bit of history there
have been 41 multi-state conventions uh
to date 11 before
1787 and 30 after afterward and not a
single one of the Fort 41 multi-state
conventions that we've experienced in
our United States of America and before
we were the United States has ever
digressed from the subject matter
limitations in the application so
there's a very very strong history of
conventions multi-state conventions
sticking to the task assigned to them
um
next this is the third level of
protection
Congress is
barred constitutionally from calling a
convention
outside of the limits specified in hcr1
how would that borrow happen it would
undoubtedly almost instantaneously be
litigated where a litigation happy
Society so should there be a convention
derived from HCR one here and uh and and
con and someone assert that the subject
matter might include
uh some environmental matter global
warming or anything else there would be
litigation against that and given the
conservative nature of the Supreme Court
the litigation would like to Prevail so
Congress would be barred from calling
the convention so that's uh protection
number three protection number four
is
the the the delegates to the convention
under law are acting a principal agent
relationship so you folks are the
principal you and the New Hampshire
legislature here you have a live
application now in HCR 40 from 2012
relative to budget balancing and debt
limit
so should you appoint delegates
associated with HCR 40
those those delegates are your agents
you folks sitting in the room and you
have a you have a you have a you have a
power over them so should they dig
digress from the charge you've given
them in HCR one or in this case hdr40
they are breaching uh the the the the
implied contract from you you already
have that power 15 states have gone a
bit beyond that then they've passed a
delegate limitation law 15 states have
done this you folks have heard one last
Friday you heard it elegant limitation
law that that takes a power you already
have that principle agent power you
already have controlling the delegates
forcing them to stick to the subject
matter limitations in your resolution in
the application so this would simply
this bill would simply speed the process
and formalize it so that's protection
number four protection number five
the um is is is a law you might pass
protection number six
uh you folks appoint likely you will be
the people who will appoint the
delegates to the amendment convention
and this is where it gets a little
emotional I trust you folks to appoint
delegates number one that will stick to
the task that you've assigned to them
you folks will have written and passed
the legislation in hcr1 describing the
task of the delegates I'm I'm confident
you folks will appoint delegates who
will stick to that task not only that
delegates who will work very hard to
find consensus around language
reflecting the task the charge you give
them I have confidence you and I have
far more confidence in you than I do in
members of Congress because I can walk
up and I can talk with you folks I can't
do that in Congress I got to pay now
somewhere in the I'm getting a little
yeah to get a walk and talk in the U.S
Senate is about a five to twenty
thousand dollar campaign contributions I
don't have to do that to talk with you
folks so I trust you folks
uh protection number seven
should delegates propose an amendment
outside the charge you've given them for
example here in HCR one
Congress would be forbidden by the
Constitution from sending that proposal
that proposed amendment back to the
States for potential ratification
because it digresses from the charge
originally given to the delegates and to
the amended convention and again there
would be litigation should Congress
attempt to set back a uh send back to
the States for potential ratification
a proposed amendment outside the charge
protection
number eight
I'll skip beyond that one and protection
number nine which is uh really the
strongest one of all and this has been
mentioned and it can be stated very
briefly and this is the one because I've
been on the phone for about a month
talking with people about this article 5
process and I've heard the concerns
about it they're almost entirely
concerns about the runaway convention
this is your strongest protection of all
let's say all those other eight veils of
protection fail and a rogue Amendment
somehow gets back to the States for
ratification it requires 38 states to
ratify and if you heard it takes only 13
of 99 legislative bodies in this country
to kill any amendment that is not number
one well thought out understandable by
the people reflects the will of the
people and is is supported broadly
across the political Spectrum anything
coming out as a convention to propose
amendments that does not fulfill those
criteria is Dead on Arrival 13
legislative bodies out of 99 can kill it
that's that's the ultimate protection so
so that's
my testimony to all of you and speaking
to just maybe the Democrats on on the
committee here and the Democrats in this
body here hopefully this will come back
to the floor for debate
if you read the three-part application
here and I'm speaking for myself on this
just for myself this is my personal
opinion
if you look at the second feature the
second leg of this three-part
application limiting the power of the
federal government
if you look at our campaign money system
we have right now and again this is my
personal View
we have a campaign money system that has
become very very federalized due to the
Supreme Court's citizens united decision
of 2010. that decision stripped from uh
you folks here in the state and all the
states the power to regulate campaign
money except money direct to candidates
that power was completely stripped from
you by an act of the federal government
the federal Supreme Court without a
factual basis by the way power stripped
from you completely and from Congress
so this is a a matter of a federal the
federal court removing in 2010 a power
from you to stop things like Chinese
money coming into elections for members
of Congress here in the state and again
remember I ran for the U.S Senate in
2014 2016. I've experienced some of this
stuff it stripped from you the power
here in the state to say we want our
legislators we want our candidates of
whatever party to reflect our viewpoints
our unique uh value system our unique
issue priorities that reflect here in
the state of New Hampshire the money
system we have right now imposed upon
you here in New Hampshire by the federal
government through the Supreme Court
strips the power that you have to say we
want our candidates to reflect our
issues priorities we want our candidates
to reflect our values in our state as
opposed to a Super PAC from California
or run by
Senator Schumer or senator McConnell
this is the way the money system right
now highly federalized suppressing local
candidates suppressing local viewpoints
so here's where this cos uh this this
three-part resolution comes in limiting
the power of the federal government
and I again I'm a volunteer with wolf
pack okay wolf pack has three states now
with live applications
on the way to 34. that's a long way from
three this application is at 19 States
on its way to 34. this application this
is why Democrats ought to get behind
there right now it's mostly red states
that have adopted this resolution in
their states purple States and blue
States ought to be doing this because
this is in my view this is a direct
Pathway to giving States once again the
power to take Chinese money out of your
elections to take Super PAC money from
California or wherever else you don't
like out of your elections so that we in
New Hampshire can control
our selection of members of Congress
once again
so and I believe that that any such a
delegate proposing language restoring to
States this power
uh would be Jermaine uh to this uh this
language in in this HCR one and so I'll
stop there and uh happy to answer any
questions and thank you members of the
committee for your time I hope this
comes out of your committee with a
unanimous unanimous recommendation of
ought to pass unanimous
well thank you Senator I representative
Kerry
missing number eight so what is number
eight please
well they're they're on this uh did you
get the uh this image you could just for
the record be easier than me digging out
paper oh okay yes yeah I put my glasses
on forgive me
I'm trying not to repeat stuff so
this is number eight is the uh this is
Congress being constitutionally barred
from submitting back to the States and I
mentioned this briefly
Congress being constitutionally barred
from submitting back to the States again
for potential ratification a proposed
amendment that came that may come out of
the convention but that does not adhere
to the subject matter limitations in
this case in hcr1
so there would be litigation about that
I'm confident that this whole process
will be process would be monitored in
real time by legal legalize across the
country and that such filings for uh for
runaway uh proposed amendments would be
objected to by litigation very promptly
yeah other questions for Senator Rubens
Senator Senator representative Massimo
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question most welcome
um do you believe as as many people do
that
um
if there was the chance like say we got
to the 33 State application that
Congress might then be forced to take up
the subject that the convention was
going to originally take up absolutely
about about thank you I didn't get to
that my written testimony covers this
but about half of the 27 present
amendments to the U.S Constitution
probably happen because of this article
5 state-led process the Congress feels
the heat sees the light that we we
already heard about the Bill of Rights
having originated as a result of
pressure from the states the 17th
Amendment related to direct election of
U.S senators so so this process here and
again this this applies to all members
of this committee if you have some
degree of lack of confidence in this
process
this process has been successful in
getting Congress to get up off its stuff
and deal with the issues again the
issues being covered here are broadly
broadly supported by the American public
Congress thus far will not act
any any extent to which we increase the
number of states in this case from 19 up
toward Thirty thirty four is going to
increase pressure on Congress to get its
act in gear and and do what uh do what
the American people want
thank you yeah
and the questions for Senator Rubens
thank you
not seeing any thanks senator
[Applause]
okay a couple things again as I
mentioned before we have a tradition
here we try to avoid uh signaling or
Applause so I do need to uh to pass that
on a second time
uh The Honorable Fenton ground is is he
here very yes uh another Rochester very
well represented today uh welcome back
uh
uh honorable Fenton Brown
thank you
uh I will not go into the details of how
this works because you've heard a whole
lot about that I do believe it's a very
safe process I was the sponsor of a uh
Article 5 resolution when I was in the
Senate in 2011 it passed in 2012 and I
might say it passed 19 to five in the
Senate and with I believe a 60 or 61
percent majority in the house at that
point so I won't go into that what I
want to talk about is why is it neat so
first of all I believe it's a safe
process I believe we should do it
I believe that the danger of not doing
it is far greater than the danger of a
Runway convention so I want to talk
about
what the purpose of this is so the first
purpose that's limited here is to impose
fiscal restraints on the federal
government
now looking at the committee here I see
a few of you that were here in 1980 as I
was not here in this room but here on
this Earth uh in 1980
you wonder what the federal debt was in
1980.
it's 918 billion
in 1980. and I thought that was awful
918 billion
in 2003
excuse me in in 1998 25 years ago it was
3.8 trillion
in 2003 five years later it was 6.8
trillion in 2012 when we passed the
resolution in the Senate and then the
house
it was 16 trillion and today it is 31.5
trillion so just to put this in
perspective I won't give percentages
because they're too big to give that is
a
34.3 Time increase
since 1980 in our federal debt it is an
8.3
multiplier increase since 1998
4.6 cents
2003 doubled since 2012.
now let's talk a little bit about the
debt
for years as you know we had Rock Bottom
interest rates
the federal debt was being serviced at
under two percent
today
Treasurer bonds are being sold for over
four percent
you take that two percent difference in
interest
it's 630 billion dollars a year Point
Six Trillion a year increase in service
of the federal debt that's without the
federal debt growing
what's that going to do to inflation
going on what's that going to do to
budget going on
now what brings this about
so
that comes to the second part of it the
reining in the power of the federal
government
I'm contractor general contractor for 18
years we Built Homes and some commercial
today were strictly a Commercial
contractor
I've been a member for many years in the
National Association of Home Builders
their statistics I saw in December they
came out and they said that today for
the price of a new home and we all know
we want to have affordable housing for
the price of a new home 41.5 percent of
the cost of a new home is due to
regulations
okay now we know some of those are
needed and I won't argue that but some
of them are way overboard
the bigger problem with it is that most
many if not most of those regulations
are not created by the federal
government or even by the state they're
created by
either private or federal or state
bureaucracies
yes I know there's an approval process
but the approval process generally does
not deal with the specifics as is when
we approve a new building code here in
New Hampshire
so we need and especially in the federal
government level we need that brought
back more to the power of limiting that
power of anybody but the legislature
making that uh making those regulations
I'm very familiar with something that
that's called waldus w-o-t-u-s
and if you're not in construction or
issues regarding land use or probably
not familiar with that that's called
Waters of the United States
the Waters of the United States when the
bill was passed I believe it was in the
70s
was navigable Waters
and defined as something you can run a
vote on initially that was
Rivers such as the Mississippi and
Missouri that were navigable for
Commerce
eventually it was added that it was
inevitable by boats in general
in I believe it was
2014 or 15.
a an executive order came out and then
was followed up by rules that expanded
waldus the Waters of the United States
to be anything that fed a navigable
water
and as a result a man-made ditch that
was created
by a farmer
and had water run through it
periodically and might have some Wetland
grasses and stuff in it became Waters of
the United States
and became subject to that regulation
it added trillions trillions of dollars
to development costs
much of that stays in place today that
was not approved by Congress that was
not put in by Congress we need an
ability to Reign this in we need an
ability for Congress to challenge such
rules and be more effective in it that
would be that could be part of this type
of a process we know what's happened
with executive orders under both
Democrats and Republicans executive
orders have taken on the the level of
Law and their I don't believe they're
being challenged properly by the courts
over Congress
do we need this we need it desperately
and we need it now
thank you
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions and the questions for former
Senator going
on thank you for coming here from from
Rochester
okay the honor The Honorable Kurt welper
I saw
in the house earlier is is he still here
this yes he is
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh obviously
I support this for two reasons three
reasons
one reason is I think this is something
that we absolutely need
to help unify our country
the political process we have and the
operation in Washington
has put us in a place where we haven't
had a budget in years it seems like they
can't pass a bill to
recognize the colors of the United
States flag
and will help us
you've heard a lot about the debt and
all that that's absolutely true I 100
concur
it needs to get fixed but it isn't
getting fixed we're going to be putting
a couple million on here whatever next
week next month trillion I meant
it's ridiculous
so we have to fix it
and the founders gave us away
this is the way
the lawsuit that's out there
that we want the Attorney General to be
the prime sponsor
is a necessary step in that because
Congress is failing to do its job
it doesn't
tally
requests
and it doesn't thereby know or recognize
when a valid Article 5 request has been
made
and if it does they just must be with
those other classifying documents that
went somewhere else
so
I just see this is something we have to
do you can't get done any other way in
my view and and
this has not been an unknown problem for
the past 40 or 50 years it's been
discussed on a regular basis
time to get moving and the way to do it
unfortunately
is to force Congress to do its job
thank you
thank you and the questions for The
Honorable Kurt welcome
not seeing any The Honorable
Erica Victoria Eastman is she from
Nashville or is she here still
I'm not seeing her
okay moving along I I want to make a
quick comment or two here I will be here
as long as it takes I very much enjoyed
being here that's why I wanted to be
here
um I sponsored a Civics bill it's now a
lot of this not not all the uh the uh
members will be able to stay for the
whole duration I will be here and most
of us will be here uh so as we move
along here I still have a good a pretty
good stack of pink cards
um as we go through these uh I don't
want to limit anybody's test testimony
if we can avoid that I want to you took
the time to travel here and I want to
hear and you want to others want to hear
what you have to say so we will just
simply ask if if the Salient main points
that you want to make have already been
stated then you don't need to
necessarily elaborate on what has been
said I would say that and if everybody
wants to waive off you certainly can
and I finally I will point out that this
is streaming live uh it will be on
YouTube uh I know Senator Rubens is
still here but the uh his eighth Point
whoever's watching or gonna watch on
YouTube would have wanted to know that
eighth point
uh we're so Kerry I'm glad you asked
that
so we will uh move right along I see
some folks have asked for five minutes
three minutes three minutes
um and we want to honor your request and
your your time uh but again if uh if
if uh if some of the points have been
made uh feel free to not repeat them so
let's now go to uh L brendano who I've
seen before and there he is
thank you very much
um chairman Moffett and committee my
name is Al brendano I am the state
director for the convention States
and may I begin in this beautiful Hall
and I always am overwhelmed when I look
around me of the people who've come
before us and what they've had to
do in our in for the benefit of all of
us but I want to start with the words of
Alexander Hamilton in 1788 federalist
51.
if men were Angels no government would
be necessary
if Angels were to govern men neither
external or internal controls on
government would be necessary
in that spirit I rise today in support
of hcr1
the resolution of the convention of
states to Simply propose amendments to
this U.S Constitution and not change it
you may ask me why I ask you why not
One Federal term limits why not over 80
percent of the U.S population is in
support of it
it's interesting if you look at Congress
and the Senate they have a 19 approval
rating yet they're elected 95 percent of
the time
if you're a lobbyist who would you be
investing in
number two fiscal responsibility
why not it's supported by 70 percent of
the U.S voters in fact today when you
left your house your house your wife or
husband probably asked you before you
left if um if you know we were going to
make the budget this week or we had to
cut back on something
well guess what the nonpartisan
Congressional budget office just this
week agrees with you
they told us that social security
could go bust as early as 2033
and Medicare trust fund insolvency by
2027.
number three
return to states rights why not
1776 Colonel Mason the father of article
5. and Visionary of Liberty
Guided by the wisdom of federalist 51
got unanimous consent of No Greater body
of men of wisdom ever assembled in
history at the time of the Constitution
imagine that
at that time 90 percent of the power of
the government
would be governed by the States today
it's nearly reversed ninety percent is
federal and 10 percent is the states
yet sadly seven years for seven years
I've come before your committee
and this committee has prevented debate
to the full floor of the house
and it's been blocked away maybe for
politics or uh even shamefully misguided
fear
during this time that we've been unable
to address this
the federal government has run away to
31 trillion dollars
I want to I want to indicate and show
you what 31 trillion is we talk about it
but we don't know it's 18 round trips
from the Earth to the Sun and back a
dollar laid end to end
think about that for a minute that's
what it is
according to Janet Yellen today the
Federal Reserve has taken an
extraordinary effort to not default
and this is what I've taken in my bag
for the last seven years
these little shoes
and they mean something to me because
what they mean to me is
we're putting our children our
grandchildren and our great
grandchildren in servitude these little
shoes
when we talk about voting on these
things we don't think about this this is
the future
and we're putting them in servitude and
we can't do that and we must act
for our national security is also a
great risk
members of this committee is my sworn
Duty and sworn all to exercise and
protect the Constitution
as you do not parts of it but all of it
Democrat independent Republican
libertarian to come together in a
peaceful way to form a more perfect
union
I have great faith in you
to do the Justice of the people and the
state of New Hampshire
you will do well in the signers and
following the signers their wisdom their
courage and the Visionary of Colonel
Mason
who inspired the principles vertical
five
please I urge you
vote to pass hcr1 out of your committee
for it is only right and just
that the whole body politic must have
the ability to speak for the people of
New Hampshire
on this constitutional matter so help us
God thank you
thank you Mr brandano
[Applause]
okay it looks like we're moving along
the way Nathaniel lavecchio and Brodie
lavecchio are they still hear
uh would you mind coming up to the
microphone in tandem it looks like
you're together you're both from
Nottingham yes uh yes sir
uh
are you both speaking
um
we can or I can just speak it doesn't
matter I have both your name somebody if
you both stand up there and uh and
you've asked for uh only a minute a
piece so um welcome
thank you good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen of the committee my name is
Nathaniel lavecchio and I'm here to
speak on behalf of the calling a
Convention of the states
I'm
sorry
I'm asking that you please approve
hcr1 the reason being the chaos spending
of
our country's Resources by Congress I'm
17 years old therefore I cannot vote yet
and I cannot vote on what my taxes are
being used for
this means my generation and the future
Generations after my time are going to
be held responsible for the debt of
which we couldn't even vote on not only
that but with Congress having no time
limits set in place
our voices will likely never be
understood by the current Congress
with that I would lastly like to say
Winston Omnia where it toss and thank
you all for your time
hello my name is Brody and I'll be
speaking as well as on behalf of
convention Estates
um I'm asking you to vote Yes the reason
that um me and my brother as well as all
of our generation will be the future of
America and I feel what I'm sorry now I
feel like we are not being represented
as the younger new generation and I also
feel like even though I cannot work or
vote that my future tax dollars are
being spent carelessly without any minor
thought on where they're going to
um
with that being said
thank you all for your time and have a
good afternoon
you take any questions if there are any
does we can accept any questions if you
like
does anyone have any questions for
Nathaniel or Brody
Cena thank you both for taking the time
to be here thank you very much
thank you very much for listening to us
the representative former representative
for Nashua is that
yes if you come up and uh for a clerk if
you state your name
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Erica Victoria
Eastman and your past lifetime served
here in this helgus chamber very proudly
and it's a thrill to be back uh before
my former committee as it happens
I'm just here to speak briefly about
change and imperative
life has changed we've all heard that
adage
sometimes big changes occur in
everyone's life and in the course of the
lifetime of a nation that have
tremendous imperatives other times as
little stuff
but when those imperatives present
themselves
we find ourselves faced with unknown
factors
and unknown uh strategies or unclear
strategies in order to confront them
overcome them and move on
and hopefully move on to a better place
I know a little bit about change quite
evidently and this nation certainly does
too
the mechanism of Article 5 is simply a
road map
has it ever been done
well attempts have been made
many many many times
but the actual manifestation
of a Convention of States is an
unprecedented event here in this country
does that mean it's not viable of course
not
lots of people in the course of their
lives confront change
for which they have no roadmap all they
have is conviction
and imperative
and they handle it
they innovate if they have to
improvise
in this particular instance in the life
of our nation we don't have to do that
we have a roadmap we have president
we have a mechanism in place
I've confronted immense change in my
life and didn't have one of those didn't
have any of that
so what does it take
[Music]
it takes a recognition
of the degree of imperative
why
[Music]
fix this
well if the Y is big enough the what
will present itself as you go
luckily in this case we have a what
but now we also have a why
bear that in mind members of the
committee please as you move forward
to vote on this matter
the why is valid
the what
is already delineated in our founding
documents
the precedent for that what it exists
throughout the course of history in this
nation
remain focused on the why
A change is hard change is good and it's
inevitable
thank you for your time
would you take any questions if there
are any
uh representative Kerry
clarification are you rising in support
of this
I am your support thank you of this
resolution representing the people of
Nashua
thank you
okay speaking in opposition to the bill
I have here next up Ross Payne from
Merrimack is Ross here
Ross Payne
p-a-y-n-e
and I
and you are not Ross Payne or you are
Ross Payne
okay well welcome
okay um
Mr chairman members of the committee
ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon I'm from Merrimack
I oppose hcr1
it attacks what makes America the
greatest nation in all history
it's not our land and natural resources
or our people who have fled from tyranny
it's the Constitution
that has kept us free
part two
and a half centuries
it does not need to be fixed it just
needs to be obeyed
okay because we the people
have made poor choices at The Ballot Box
the source of our runaway federal
government
is the image that looks back at us from
the mirror
there are other ways to limit Federal
power and the state government has a
checks and balance and that's State
nullification
Article 5 conventions are dangerous for
documented historical precedents reveal
that James Madison
observation that he trembles with the
results of a second convention is wisdom
that is
critical the passing judgment on Article
5 conventions
as early as 1776 Madison saw the dangers
that loom in our future if another
another article 5 convention becomes
reality
where the founders invoked the premise
in the Declaration of Independence that
the people held a self-evident right to
alter
or abolish their government and set up a
new government to throw off British
Monarchy monarchy
the second time Madison invoked this
self-evident right to throw off tyranny
in 1787 to replace the Articles of
Confederation the fact that both George
Soros
and the Koch brothers and many socialist
billionaires
fund this movement doesn't this mean
they have bought the opinions of cos and
Wolfpack
my eyes are not what they used to think
their con job is it can't be a runaway
convention
but because any Article 5 convention is
a representation of The Sovereign will
of the people the threat is we will
duplicate what happens in 1787.
unfortunately Washington Madison
Hamilton and Jay will not be there to
guard our Liberty
don't you think it's time
that Mark meckler
of cos accepts the John Birch society's
expert on this subject Robert Brown
challenged a ten thousand dollar
challenge that was given I believe in
Montana several years ago
to debate Robert Brown on this issue I'd
like to see him
come to New Hampshire and debate Robert
Brown
I believe that's and I have a picture of
I will give committee a picture but wolf
pack
in 2016.
their lobbyist Ryan Clayton standing in
the front hall obviously
wolf pack lobbyist
Ryan Clayton
in Concord in 2016. there's a bunch of
ladies
that don't want
Convention of states or wolf packs
convention calls and they got signs
that Mr Clayton is standing out in front
of them
and they don't know it but he's has a
sign language for him
a vulgar sign language right here in his
stomach
so I don't think that's too much class
maybe we're going to do law school I
don't know
but that's my uh
my uh my presentation and I like to give
the committee a copy of my
life thank you miss me yes if you could
get that up here so we can get it to our
clerk for our our record
and thank you for coming up here for
Merrimack
jointerio uh asked for two minutes to
speak for the bills John
there there he is
from King uh representing himself
thank you Mr chair
uh I stood before this committee six
years ago
to speak in favor of a similar
resolution the convention of state's
resolution at the time
it was hcr4 and the main sponsor was The
Honorable Frank adelblue some of you may
know him as our education commissioner
it passed this committee unanimously
OTP
it got held up administratively and on
the floor of the house in one of those
Marathon sessions before the crossover
it got tabled because a small number of
Representatives threatened to filibuster
at 7 pm at night and everybody wanted to
go home and have dinner and see their
family
I don't want that to happen again
but ask yourself this in the six years
since this committee
said this should pass
OTP unanimously
has the debt been reduced
now
has the federal government
overreached less
no
is the influence of lobbyists and dark
money on incumbent politicians less
no everything is gone in the wrong
direction and you have the power to
start the wheel turning that gives the
American people the opportunity
to write this ship
the Constitution gives State
legislatures the co-equal responsibility
with Congress
to propose amendments not to not to do
anything else other than to propose them
Congress can do it directly you can do
it through a conventional States
please do your duty
and forward HCR one with the unanimous
agreement that it ought to pass the
house and please get it on the calendar
early so we don't get jammed up
in the crossover period thank you
thank you take any questions
are there any questions ever so Kerry
so why do you think this has repeatedly
failed here in New Hampshire as I said
we've got a small
group of folks who oppose a convention
on what I would call
emotional terms
they're convinced that it would run away
they're convinced that it would be a
danger to the Constitution especially to
the Second Amendment both of which are
bunk
but they're convinced and no amount of
facts no amount of history as uh Dr
Ferris talked about or
uh will sway them and that's why it has
to if it needs to go to a full debate on
the house
so that all the house can can
talk to this minority make up their own
minds and make and have a reasonable
time to to debate and vote on it I think
that's the best thing that can happen
yeah
other questions
you see Nanny thank you again for taking
the time to be here and for your
testimony is Christine
lavecchio here it's a third lavecchio
with the other probably with the the two
boys
she'd ask for one minute I uh
I think that we're good with her
um Charles Krauss Miss Charles here
Charles is here from Peterborough
representing himself speaking for the
Bill he asked for a few a few minutes or
a few moments uh thank you Mr chairman
the committee uh I'm happy to be here uh
I think most of what I was going to say
has been said uh but uh we'll just bear
with me for a moment or two uh the uh
the debt burden was mentioned several
times today it's a colossal burden
uh I was born in Washington DC 77 years
ago and I remember the year 2000 I think
when Clinton was President and the
Congress was doing its job we actually
had a couple of surpluses
and also from from uh
1789 to 1930
that's like 140 years we only had about
40 deficit years and that included the
Civil War and a couple of other terrible
things so uh it's really gotten it's
it's unbelievable I don't know where the
gentleman was speaking of before that
thought things were getting better
unbelievably better and worse and uh
many of the risks and uncertainties have
been addressed nicely to have a
convention
and also if you don't have a convention
where is this country going to go
it's unbelievable to me and I grew up my
mother was born in Jaffrey New Hampshire
I was I've spent almost all my life in
New Hampshire and uh it's a wonderful
state
it's a well-run state it's fiscally
conservative and uh people are respected
and the people are nice and we don't
have the crime and the bad water and the
bad air and everything else but uh at
the at the federal level the old saying
all power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
and it's been proven in Spades uh in the
last
number of years and we've got a a
congress
uh which writes vague legislation so
that an unelected bureaucracy can do all
kinds of
horrible things that really stymie my
sister spent 17 years building a
community theater in Jaffe New Hampshire
it took us 17 years to pass all the
regulations and the zoning and this and
that and bringing power in and now it's
a wonderful It's a Wonderful community
structure right now with all kinds of
artistic events from the grade schools
and elementary schools and colleges in
the area and Civic groups all kinds of
things so but that shows you the I mean
today what do we need we don't have a
shortage of natural gas we need
pipelines we can't build a pipeline
the the great navigable Rivers Act was
passed like in the 1970s it was supposed
to be for bodies of water they could
transport large ships
carrying goods in merchandise and now
apparently if you've got a a a a spring
Vernal pool in your backyard they can
they can oversee that it's just uh
it's just a a very unfortunate and it
improves the old outage the road to hell
is paved with good intentions people
mean well but the power is just uh uh
something that is really the and that's
what the founders worried about they had
the three branches of the federal
government they had the shared federal
state uh uh federalism which to diffuse
power
now we have presidents that have
executive orders Congress which doesn't
do which job they don't the United
States senators and representatives you
know until recently all they could do
was sit in the very end say yes or no
they couldn't offer amendments they
couldn't have to face the Committees
were shambles this was the United States
Congress
it's just unbelievable so I think the
dangers are much greater if you do
nothing and and this is going to be a
wonderful thing it can be a wonderful
thing and we have wonderful people today
talking about it so I I certainly uh
would uh hope everybody here uh can get
on board and do us
the representative here said to have
unanimous passage to the main body of
the house thank you very much
thank you sir for coming all the way
from Peterborough
uh Jerome Gates is Jerome still Jerome
is here
from moultonborough all the way from
moultonborough
speaking uh three minutes for the bill
for the measure uh Mr chairman and
committee members my name is Jerome
Gates I'm from moultonborough in Carroll
County
understandably when discussing Article 5
of The Constitution and the convention
Estates most people focus on the many
serious problems that exist with our
federal government today out of control
spending the usurption of power and the
lack of transparency but I'd like to
spend the brief amount of time that I
have with you today mentioning the
process of conventionist states which I
think is equally important
and I'm not talking about the 34 states
that are needed to hold the convention
of States I think there's more to it
than that foreign formidable requirement
if you mentioned
any one of the topics under hcr1
most people have pretty strong opinions
about them
but until now there hasn't been a forum
for the average citizen to join in the
debate and yet these issues are vitally
important to the future of Our Country
Convention of states will provide us
with the Forum needed to discuss and
debate these important topics some of
the proposals might actually be approved
but any proposal that's approved must be
sent back to all of the states for
consideration
and you and then we need 38 state
legislatures to approve it you know
better than most how hard it is to get
anything approved in a state legislature
let alone 38 of them
so anyone concerned about a runaway
convention
should take comfort in the fact that
there will be no approve or no amendment
to the Constitution unless 38 State
legislatures approve it
the important thing this is my main
point today is that there be a debate
if you have a debate people will be
satisfied that we were at least able to
have the discussion
in a format that was not being
controlled by federal government
employees many of whom are more
concerned with maintaining their power
even at the expense of our future
so I urge you to allow us to have the
debate by approving hcr1 thank you
thank you Mr Gates uh would you take any
questions
if there are any questions for Mr Gates
thank you very much thank you
Joe torelli is Joe still here
Joe is here what welcomes Joe from
Hampton uh speaking up to five minutes
for the bill I'll do my best and I
promise not to read from this book
um my name is Joe torelli I live in
Hampton
I am a constitutional I do I Define
myself as a constitutional libertarian
because I am so often frustrated and
re repulsed by the Democrat Party and
the Republican party and their
activities and what they do in our in
our nation's capital
and what I want to expose and Elevate is
something that representative Potenza
mentioned earlier as did state senator
um ribbons this is totally nonpartisan
everything about this is nonpartisan
when
when John Langdon had to postpone
and adjourn the ratification convention
in February of 8 1788 in Exeter it was
because not enough people knew what the
record what why we needed a Federal
Constitution and one guy in Amherst
Joshua Atherton said hey I've got these
12 amendments I'd like to add to this
12 amendments
or later those 12 amendments 10 of them
became our Bill of Rights Okay so
Langdon adjourned the meeting in
February of 1788 and met up the street
here in the Old Town Meeting Hall
which sits on States sits on the
property that borders State Street and
Church Street
does that mean there's an intersection
of church and state yes
so in February they spent 10 nine days
debating three pages of the Constitution
nine days debating three pages of the
Constitution and Atherton helped to
postpone it because there was so much to
debate and discuss and so Langdon and
John Sullivan said oh well we need to
effectively using our terms today Market
why we need a Federal Constitution let's
hold off four months and meet in Concord
which they did
and on June 21st the solstice in 1788
1pm
not only did that group of people ratify
the Constitution
but New Hampshire
was the ninth state to do that
which enacted the Constitution just up
the road here the building burned down
that's where binimedia is
far right corner
and when you think about the history of
the ancestors of the state legislators
that are that are seated today
they did that
I'd say that the state legislators are
compelled as their Duty
to pass this resolution you are the
you are the check and balance
among 33 other states to be able to get
the process moving so that we can get
this to happen
so one of the things that we have and
getting back to the non-partisan nature
is that
Democrats and Republicans
in each state whether it's Bismarck
whether it's Cheyenne
whether it's Salem whether it's
Tallahassee
they should want to bring back these
funds that are being sent to Washington
to their state capitals so that the one
size fits all is kind of like oh gee
maybe it's better in the state of
Washington to do this than it is in
Missouri
and so we need to deconstruct the K
Street lobbyist influence
in Washington
by addressing the three topics that are
in this resolution
so that we can begin to change this and
bring it back and again I feel
personally
it is the duty of the state
representatives and the state senators
in each of the states to understand that
you are the people that George Mason and
James Madison
actually figured was better than what
Alexander Hamilton wanted to do with a
music track underneath
to only have Congress do it why would
Congress be the only ones to to change
the change the Constitution
it had to go back to the States because
every state was different there are only
13 at the time now we have 50. so I'm
going to finish 458 I'm done
happy to answer questions
are there any questions
or absolutely Carrie
you cited a book uh that one that's
about four inches thick would you give
me the title yes I will and even better
than that we are you know there's a a
group of us that are working on
condensed this the author condensed this
book the six-page executive summary and
I have requested of the author
the permission to reprint the six-page
executive summary
so I can get you these and I can get
them for both parties because this
attacks the attacks and provides
documented evidence of what the
different challenges were and why
this alone is 15 minutes reading time
and it's like oh my gosh I had no idea
so I offer this and more of them and we
would love to get get them in the hands
of each of the representatives so that
they can read it but we also want to
have a discussion and to talk about it I
love the book
sorry oh the book is far from unworkable
and I would love to have the ability to
put two of these in the State Library
across the street so that you all can
check it out and go to page
736 there's 820 in here I have not read
this but I have read enough of it to
know that the evidence is all in here
this is fantastic I was going to offer
that as a stand for the microphone
yes uh representative Finney I think you
had a question
the name of the book okay I'll hold it
up for the camera camera's that way okay
far from unworkable and it's Tim Dake
and he's a professor from Wisconsin and
it worked in Wisconsin it took a couple
of years
but they just passed in Wisconsin
just a follow-up would you believe that
my daughter's attended school on the
site of The Walker School which was on
the site of the previous meeting house
at the corner of church state in Boonton
how about and Putin so this is the book
the the state legislature commissioned
in 1888 on the 100th anniversary of it
this is the actual 1888 book that
describes uh walk um Langdon sending
Walker to take five of the detractors
out got them drunk so that they couldn't
make the vote stuff like that but you
know what dirty tricks or dirty tricks
so whatever but I'm happy to and I'm
happy to discuss it with anybody and go
over this and this
if anybody's interested thank you
thank you and think of the history
lesson in Brooklyn Curie so in a sense
our country was born
I think in case our country was born at
that spot and here in Concord in 1788 as
as we know it Matthew Rhodes they say
that correctly Rhodes Matthew
yes you have 20 copies for us
and we'll
we'll get those to the to the Reps who
had to leave early thank you
thank you very much for uh listening to
me today and for being here and serving
the people of New Hampshire
um
so I'll remember what FDR said is to be
sincere be brief and be seated
and uh
it's interesting here what's going on
today and I'm listening to the various
testimonies uh concerning hrc1 and I
wonder how we arrived as a nation at
this point where we would see a pack so
massive as the convention of States
project pour in such a vast amount of
resources and money into an effort that
has really no blueprint despite what
everything is being said here today
while claiming the whole time that it
does
the Herculean effort to control water
influence legislators across the country
surely could have been spent on other
efforts
that would have proven more immediately
useful and beneficial to the American
people
instead we are debating under this
Fantastical notion
that somehow term limits is the magical
answer to fixing a government
that is out of control a government that
acts immorally which ignores the
constraints the Constitution
already puts on it
on their enumerated powers which are
clearly stated in Article 1 Section 8.
so term limits will not take corrupt
people out of the circle of influence of
government and in fact makes a newer and
newer Freshman Class of naive
legislators vulnerable to these
peripherally located parasitic Army of
lobbyists that invest Washington DC and
I can tell you my ex-wife used to work
for one of them and they really can't
wait for this convention of states to
pass
so
in short the amount of hands grasping at
the public offers will not be reduced
and as some recent Studies have shown an
empirical data suggest and I think you
can look at the ncsl website they have a
very good uh article about does term
limits take people out of office
no it doesn't it doesn't reduce the
amount of time people spend in office or
in the sphere of influence over politics
what we need to do is to look for a
moral solution
is what I'm suggesting here today
and I'm not into and I'm not insinuating
that anybody here is immoral and I'm not
going to say that I don't think that
we ever intentionally do things wrong
but it is clear that sometimes we don't
follow the Constitution and that's
created the problem that we're in today
what we need to uh so I say we returned
to being a people will understand what
the government is and as Thomas
Jefferson says let the people of fully
educated people be the deposit of
Liberty in this country which we don't
have
and of course some people think and
unfortunately that the government is a
giant candy store
and our representatives are the
dispensers of goodies like the Easter
Bunny in Santa Claus and that creates
problems year after year
every year Pub Republicans and Democrats
fight over their given voters over
giving voters the things not lawfully
Allowed by the Constitution and this
Behavior has turned every election cycle
into a war zone with the American people
as victims
this is the very source of our ills
both the people and the elected
mm-hmm
corruption can only be fixed by the
electorate voting for moral people and
not those who grant them the most favors
so this isn't just a government problem
this is a people problem because for all
the people that you know like that are
out there holding public office you have
to remember there's somebody that voted
for them and those are the people that
don't understand what our our
constitution says so if we go in and get
everybody out of the picture and within
it within a year or another cycle will
have the same type of people back in
even if it's just for a short time so
um
let's start today with every legislator
in this room committing to upholding
their oath to the Constitution stop
taking Federal money that'd be a good
place to start reducing the size of the
government you just have to say no it's
very simple it says so in the article 6
of The Constitution not required to take
all that big Federal money that's coming
your way if you want less government you
have to be part of that solution so
so with the participation of our elected
officials and the people we can return
ourselves to the place of honor that
America was in at one time
and that's all I have to say and I thank
you very much for your time
thank you
thank you for your time and for being
here
there is a card here from
Lucy Everly ever love is she said she
just has a written testimony
it is
okay
Lucy yeah okay you know uh well welcome
uh from Manchester sure in your SP
doesn't say if you're for or against the
measure
I'm here to speak in uh favor of the
convention at Article Five okay
um
and I just want to say a convention is
imminent
it's happening
um in your lifetime
we're going to have a convention in this
country under Article 5 of The
Constitution and legislators met from
all across the country and
um they were a bipartisan group
they were authorized by their
legislative Chambers they were called
the Assembly of state legislators and
they came up with rules
these rules are not binding but they
were proposed by a bipartisan group of
legislators they were negotiated in
Earnest from the people that were
attending and I do believe that this is
the blueprint for what the procedures
will be at the convention so I just
wanted to let everybody here on the
committee know those that are you voted
for a convention for other matters and
those of you who voted against in the
past I want you to imagine what a
convention looks like when you read
these because I think what it looks like
is this chamber
I think it looks like these people
sitting in the seats I think it looks
like the committee here before us today
and maybe it'll be here
you know but imagine what would happen
if regular people or legislators state
legislators from across the country got
together to talk about seriously in
Earnest what should we do about the
problems facing our country and how can
we propose amendments to the
Constitution to the rest of the states
so that they can have a chance and a
choice to say whether or not they want
that Amendment added so I would
encourage you all to think very
seriously about the prospect of article
5. it's in the Constitution it's there
since the beginning and anyone who
opposes this on the grounds of Article 5
on the idea of a convention I would just
ask you what other parts of the
Constitution do you want to ignore
do you want to ignore the first
amendment do you want to ignore the
Second Amendment or any of the other
Bill of Rights because the way we got
those like the gentleman mentioned
earlier
is by using the convention and applying
the pressure to Congress getting them to
propose it and then ratifying them
through the states
so this is a state driven process
you're the legislators that get to
decide whether or not this happens and
so we ask you
please consider Article 5 an essential
part of the Constitution an essential
check and balance and remember that
there are rules that have been
negotiated by most of the legislative
bodies and their authorized
representatives and I can give a copy I
only have three sorry I didn't print
enough but I can give you a copy of
these and you can read them it looks
like pretty similar to your rules
so thank you for your time
any questions
are there any questions
if you could get at least one of those
copies up here to the clerk that would
be great I'll do that thank you
[Applause]
okay we still have a few more cards I
have one two three four five
six
uh
and I just got Ken's Kem Quinn last so
uh so you'll know your last is Ken
okay yeah Ken so you'll be the just you
know you'll be the final speaker
and um Eric Sapp
is Eric Eric is here welcome
Eric is speaking for the bill for one or
so minutes uh and he's addressed uh I
can't I read that but Eric he'll tell us
where you're from please
good afternoon
and thank you for your patience
to sit and listen to all of this all day
long is a very tough job and we all
appreciate it thank you
I'm Eric straff and I'm from Center
Harbor
I rise today
because I'm 78 years old
I have five grandchildren
and I love this nation
that's over four 300 334 trillion
dollars in debt
our federal government
is working even as we speak
to increase
the national debt limit
so they can run that 34 trillion through
the roof
you
are the only ones who can fix this
problem
you are the ones who call a Convention
of states
you can choose the delegates from New
Hampshire
you can chew uh you can set the rules
for the delegates
if a delegate does something wrong you
can recall them
if uh you will vote for ratification
before any proposed amendment
becomes law and part of our constitution
please remember to
a Convention of states is not a
political issue
Democrats
have grandchildren
Republicans
have children
Independence
Undeclared
have grandchildren
We're All in This Together
one last note and that is for you people
you
Representatives
to bear in mind that you are only a
small part of the 400 Representatives we
have in New Hampshire
I hope you will give all of them
an opportunity
to vote for their children
and grandchildren thank you
thank you for your time and for
traveling down here
uh would you take any questions if there
are any
seeing them
you you've been here before I say see
none thanks again for coming down here
Terence Waldron
is right there uh Terence from East
Kingston representing himself in favor
of the bill
in favor of the resolution I should say
I am in favor yeah my name is Terence
Waldron of East Kingston Rockingham
County
sorry Deb Hobson is my representative
and I have three pages here but I think
it's going to go down to a couple
paragraphs in deference to your request
to not repeat
first thing that struck me today and
it's not all my testimony is the fact
that we have
wolf pack here today U.S term limits
here today convention Estates here today
we have people from all different
political views testifying to you today
say it we need this
very interesting they're coming at it
from all different directions and
they're all coming to the same
conclusion
I'm an engineer by train if I have
people solve a problem from two
different directions and they come to
the same conclusion it's probably pretty
damn good
just adding one little note to the whole
31 and a half that you have heard all
day long
last year we paid five percent of the
national budget
for interest
at current interest rates four percent
that's what t-bells are going you know
some a little some above and below
that's going to move to 18 very quickly
could you imagine what you could do with
1.2 trillion dollars if you weren't
paying interest on it
the heart of the matter
is the balance of power
sorry it's going to be a little choppy
because I'm skipping
when the Articles of Confederation were
developed you had about a 90 10 split of
power 10 to the federal government 90 to
the state
Constitution was developed that
rebalanced a bit 40 federal government
60 State today
I think you'd be hard-pressed to say 10
is left in the state the federal
government is now dominating States and
they're doing it with money
they're borrowing money to control
States
you've all seen
the funding that has come in it always
comes in with strengths
that's how they're doing it a Convention
of States allows you
to take that federal government and
restrain them give them some guard reps
keep them from doing that to you pull
the power back to yourself get it back
to a 50 50. something in that range
that's the idea of the convention of
states
put the guard rails in place
on the issue of term limits I just
finished a book that
really it's a story of Billy Bulger and
Whitey Bulger
but nested inside that story
hour of Billy Bulger and how Billy
Bulger over years and years and years
and years accumulated that power and
became an Unstoppable force in
Massachusetts politics
had there been term limits
I don't think Billy would have ever
gotten to where Billy got
think about that
turning over Congress turning over the
Senate will stop the accumulation of
power the most powerful people in both
Chambers have been there for quite a
while I'll leave you with that thought
one last item on my thoughts
we spoke about our children
we have a state motto live free and die
Congress has a motto live free and pay
later
I can't match Mike Farris and his army
of grandkids I've got four
but I have the same thoughts as him
we cannot spend today and burden our
children
with the shackles of debt they can never
realize live free
another book I read yes I read too much
history I apologize
it's a great book called American Rebels
it's the story of the atoms Quincy and
Hancock family
and there's a thread that goes through
that whole book
and that is these were people of action
they saw a problem they took action they
solved the problem
it took years
took a lot of sweat Blood Sweat and
Tears
but they solved it
it was a fellow named Joshua Quincy no
one's probably ever really heard of
Joshua Joshua was the Thomas Jefferson
of that period
before the Continental congresses Joshua
went to every single state
got them on board they weren't States
sorry colonies at the time Joshua went
to England he spent time with Ben
Franklin Joshua died in 1775 coming back
from England consumption so we lost a
great man
but most of the early writings were in
Joshua Quincy's pet
and he had a saying that I want to leave
you with
it is yourselves
it is yourselves must save you
and you are equal to the task
I look at this committee and that's what
I think
it is up to you to save us by changing
the direction of the federal government
put the guard rails on them using
article 5.
and I think you're up to the task thank
you
thank you thank you
and seeing
Roosevelt Kerry has her hand up yes
do you have a piece of paperwork you
might want to submit for the record
in your how about if I clean this up Can
I submit it by email or I can use your
website to submit it yeah I'll do that
anything else
thank you again
Joshua McAllister from Manchester
has written testimony is Joshua here
okay I don't know if his written
testimony was dropped off or send
electronically
did I don't know if he said he had
written testimony
um do you know if he
is he left or do we have his testimony
okay if you're in touch with him uh you
can tell him he can email that to the
committee to my attention and we'll get
that into our record
it doesn't say if he was for or against
the measure
okay uh Lisa Crocker from Belmont
thank you for hanging in uh Lisa you
opposed the bill and you asked for three
minutes
and I again I called the bill it is a
resolution technically
yeah
okay
[Music]
um
it's my first time so bear with me
first of all I'd like to thank all of
you for for being here I was very
pleased to see so many people show up
for this
um like our my predecessor said we are
all in this together
um
my big concern is
if the convention of states is the way
to go
it does hold a potential for being very
dangerous to our Constitution and our
country
this legislation is completely
unnecessary I feel
the for example the facts that term
limits have not put anyone at an
advantage except lobbyists when looking
at term limits uh history in other
states where they have been implemented
new or elected officials are more
vulnerable to be led or misled due to
their lack of experience
for perspective no one asks a lobbyist
to be dismissed after two to eight years
they only grow more experienced and they
learn the ins and outs of the system and
even developed the working relationships
with long-term knowledgeable staffers as
the lobbyists are there longer within
the elected officials
this gives them a much larger Advantage
the frequent turnover of electric
elected officials puts the elected
officials at a considerable disadvantage
term limits can prevent very good
elected people from being reelected and
keep them from gaining more insight and
experience which is very
counterproductive in turning the current
situation around if that is the Hope
in fact term limits already do exist
it's called voting
um furthermore to enact term limits when
undermine the people's God give them a
right to choose the representatives
uh we should also be horrifically we
should uh should we but should we were
to open the convention of States we
would get rid of our god-given rights
recognized in our constitution this
procedure is how the Articles of
Confederation was replaced by our
constitution there is a president's
precedent here and therefore it could
happen again
please do not believe the rhetoric
stating differently we could lose the
reasons that being an American is
wonderful and awesome we have rights
given by God and no government officials
can take these away
uh take away these protections as long
as we have the Constitution
if the if the concern is about federal
government having overreach and the
federal government not following the
current Constitution the states can use
nullification to stop unconstitutional
laws and honestly they are under
obligation to do so
protect their citizens nullification is
a safe way to
protect our rights keep our Constitution
and it has been used multiple times in
U.S history including in the past few
years
if you like I can bring a few examples
to you if you're interested and I can
give you some information as to how to
how the process proceeds
um
you know if you are so willing to
receive you know more information on
that subject
my main concern is
I mean it's obvious
to everyone
that we need to change my concern is
that
the
the COS opens up a lot of risk
I believe the Nullification should be
used first and foremost
doesn't mean that a COS may never never
may never come to fruition I'm
just a little bit wary of it
thank you
do you have written testimony copy that
you'd like to
thank you I can give you my what I the
thread but um and then I have those
pamphlets that's all I have right now
with me
um
uh well we do like to keep a folder of
testimony if that if that's presentable
it's up to you if uh
thank you thank you for your your time
and your travel
Larry Gomes
from Stark
okay
yeah
not everyone knows where Stark is I know
where it is and it's a long ways to the
north thanks for coming it's about 20
miles north of Mount Washington Mr
chairman it is the True North Coast
County
um thank you for allowing me to testify
today
um
miss Larry going resident of Stark and
and over the last few years our family
has been increasingly concerned about
the runaway Federal deficit to the point
we've been discussing this at
Thanksgiving you know and I'm not
talking just the older members I'm
talking to younger kids too
um there is a lot of countries in the
world where printing too much money has
caused runaway inflation uh just to
mention a few Argentina Venezuela and
Zimbabwe
and in all of these countries
uncontrolled printing led to
hyperinflation
which then resulted in the middle class
being decimated by food shortages crime
and economic depression
think about this just 30 years ago
Venezuela which has the largest oil
reserves more than Saudi Arabia used to
have a standard of living equal to the
United States and now 9 out of 10 people
cannot even feed themselves in that
country and a lot of them are leaving
the country
you know and so we talk about this
because could it happen to us and the
answer is yes
so
we had almost lost hope until I found
out about the convention of States about
a month and a half ago I didn't even
know this existed
and I started reading up what they
wanted to do I read everything I could
on Article 5 I watched eight hours of a
mock convention that they put on in
Virginia to show how the process would
work and I am convinced that this is a
solution that can work
versus the other solution which I don't
even want to imagine
and so as you know 19 states have passed
this resolution and I respectfully asked
this committee to make the New Hampshire
the 20th State to make this happen give
it a chance let it go and see where it
goes because
the other solution is coming no matter
whether we want it or not
hyperinflation is here and it's coming
so I just want to end with the framers
knew one day the federal government
would it overstep their bounds and they
gave us this legal and peaceful way
to reign in big government so I would
sincerely ask that you join our family
and the thousands of others who are part
of this movement
to make New Hampshire the 20th state to
adopt this resolution thank you very
much
okay thank you we have your written
testimony which we really appreciate is
there any questions
third
thank you for coming down from Stark
that is a long drive in
and you saw the statue right
well with history is important to a lot
of us and I appreciate that you know
what you do when you do what you did a
final uh
speaker the less pink heart I have is
for Ken Quinn
we've seen Ken before Ken I
we some of us had a presentation from so
he has some background here Ken uh
thank you for being the the final
speaker and hanging in there
thank you Mr chair distinguished
committee members my name is Ken Quinn I
am the regional director with U.S term
limits and I'm testifying in support of
hcr1
uh obviously because within the scope of
this application is a term limits
Amendment for congress
um as well as I want to see the state
legislatures utilize their Authority
Under Article 5 of the U.S Constitution
to propose needed amendments
I was so encouraged by the number of
people that showed up today
that is phenomenal
I I just love seeing so many folks who
want to see the state legislatures use
this Authority and it was great to see
Michael Ferris here today as well
um
he is has been a leader of the
reawakening of the article 5 process in
our country and he he's been a mentor to
me
um a little bit of my background I don't
think if I shared in a previous
testimony but
I used to fight that gentleman when he
first started this I used to hand out
this DVD produced by the John Birch
Society
that says beware of article 5.
they want you to be scared over the
Constitution
initially I was
until I did my own research
it didn't take me very long to realize
wow the framers were geniuses
I never knew why they put the convention
mode in Article 5 until I actually read
why
funny what happens when you start doing
some reading on your own
I immediately realized
wow this is the mechanism
that we need to use
and I called up the convention of States
at that time and I apologize for
opposing them in fact I handed out that
DVD to the legislators in my state and I
had to apologize for them because once I
realized that the information contained
in that DVD
was nothing but lies
I felt ashamed of myself for spreading
them
and I like to share something with you
and I want to bring back the spirit of
George Washington because this is
nothing new
this is a quote
from the father of our country during
the ratification of our constitution
referring to the tactics used by the
Anti-Federalists who were opposing their
ratification of the U.S Constitution
listen to our father
the opponents I expected
would Endeavor to give it an unfavorable
complexion
with a view to bias the public mind
this evidently is the case with the
writers in opposition for their
objections are better calculated to
alarm the fears
than to convince the Judgment of their
readers
they build them upon principles which do
not exist in the Constitution
which the known and literal sense of it
does not support them in
this too after being flatly told that
they are treading on untenable ground
and after an appeal has been made to the
letter and spirit thereof for reproof
and then as if the doctrine was
incontrovertible
draw such consequences as are necessary
to Rouse the apprehensions of the
ignorance and unthinking
it is not in the interest of the major
part of these characters to be convinced
I say to you today that this tactic is
exactly what is being used against this
process
they stand on no constitutional ground
this myth of a runaway convention is
nothing but a fear tactic
it is you cannot
read article 5 you cannot look at our
history
and believe that stuff
I heard one of your previous testimony
testifiers say that James Madison
trembled at the thought of this article
5 convention
the very letter they get that quote from
he describes the two types of
conventions
a constitutional convention
which we talked about earlier which
requires unanimous consent to call and
which is what the Anti-Federalists were
seeking at that time they wanted a redo
he was not referring that's what he was
referring to that convention not the
two-thirds needed to propose an
amendment convention that he supported
all throughout his life he was a strong
advocate for an article 5 convention
in fact one of your own here at Hal
shirtless I noticed he left
he wrote this in an article on the
wearer's times July 22nd 2021
he says James Madison who strongly
opposed in Article 5 convention
I can spend hours sharing with you
quotes by Madison strongly advocating
for an article 5 convention he believed
in it
and this guy runs something called Camp
Constitution
it's unbelievable how they just say
dishonor the framers
all we have to do
is read the debates during the
convention when they drafted article 5.
it's clear it's a limited convention
is limited to what two-thirds of the
states apply for
they voted against giving Article 5 the
powers of a constitutional convention
the very first article 5 application
submitted in 1789 by Virginia
was for the Bill of Rights
in the debates in Congress
now this is very powerful
over 50 members of the first Congress
were either framers of our constitution
or they were delegates to the state
ratifying conventions that ratified the
Constitution they well understood
Article 5 and if when you read the
debate in Congress every single person
that spoke on the Virginia application
knew we can't do anything until
two-thirds apply for the same subject
and then it's out of our hands
and it's out of their hands because they
knew Congress has no Authority in this
matter
they don't choose the delegates they
don't make the rules it all falls under
the states that is why they gave us the
Article 5 convention the very day on
September 15th when there were voting on
it and that's where George Mason stood
up and I'm glad he did
the way it was drafted still allowed
Congress to propose the the Amendments
that was applied for by the states and
he said no we want them to have no
Authority whatsoever in this process the
convention is the institutional rival
against Congress why in the world would
the state legislatures want to give them
any it makes absolutely no sense so this
idea that we've heard in fact
the previous testifier oh back to
Madison I highly encourage you to read
Federalist 38 because James Madison
talks about that second convention that
he trembled over and it's clear he's
talking about a constitutional
convention that the Anti-Federalists
wanted it was a complete redo that's
what he's referring to
but a gentleman previously also
mentioned a John Birch Society scholar
I laugh at that by the name of Robert
Brown
he goes and I think you have his
testimony in fact I think um Mr Matthew
Rhodes handed in his testimony looked
very familiar to me
in that testimony and what Mr Brown does
is goes around the country
he's offered a ten thousand dollar
challenge
and this was his challenge
find for me one delegate of the federal
87 Federal Convention of 1787 that stood
up and believed they had the authority
to propose a new system of government
and he says it doesn't exist it's on
your sheet there you'll see this
I've answered that challenge over five
times he owes me ten thousand dollars
I highly recommend I've got a YouTube
channel just for that ten thousand
dollars it's called All Things Article
Five I encourage you please watch my
five episodes so far
requesting the ten thousand dollar
payment because I overwhelmingly destroy
his lie
it's fear I'm tired of the fear this has
been mentioned why hasn't this continued
to get stopped
here in this committee I don't know all
I ask is we stop being fearful
I encourage this committee
in closing
so we stop being afraid of what cannot
happen cannot happen
and be excited about what can happen
imagine being able
to partake and participate
in a historic event
where you get to propose
an amendment that has been the desire of
the American people for decades and an
amendment that everybody wants except
those in power
terminals for congress simple
82 of the American people want that
this is federalism
this is the authority the framers gave
to you
now I just found this quote I'm going to
read I'm going to close this because I
was studying
about this process back in the 90s
termos is all the rage this is an
article from 1994.
if Congress is truly a representative
body which is responsive to the people
then it should propose an amendment to
the Constitution limiting congressional
terms and presented to the people for
ratification
congress's refusal to do so is the best
evidence that is not that it is not the
representative body that the framers of
the Constitution envisioned
thus giving credence to the argument
that the framers would support today's
state-imposed Congressional term
limitation
it is a sad fact that if the states are
not allowed to impose Congressional term
limits Congress never will in spite of
the will of the people the supposed
ultimate source of power
members of the committee
this
process is because the reason we're here
today is because Congress is
unresponsive to the American people
these reforms are not going to come from
Congress
we're up to what 17 amendments
already in three weeks in this session
in Congress and some of these are really
good amendments but they're not going to
see the light of day
unless you step up
and put pressure
and once you do
they will start getting in line because
they don't want you to do this
they fear you they fear your power
and that is why we are seeking your
support
all of you I would love to see unanimous
consent here
the vote ought to pass on hcr1
please the American people the people of
New Hampshire and New Hampshire in my
previous testimony should be leading the
charge because you have the experience
here in New Hampshire you sent delegates
in 2017 to draft the rules for an
article 5 convention you have had the
most conventions for proposing
amendments to your state constitution
proposing over 200 amendments to your
own Constitution
and you participate annually in an
official Convention of States known as
the uniformed law commission you are
doing it well you are well versed in
this process do not let the fear-mongers
influence your decision on this
I close but I just want to thank you for
allowing so much time today
and I want to thank everyone that showed
up and I want to thank you for seriously
considering
this resolution
thank you
thank you Ken
would you take questions if there are
any absolutely
representative Kerry
so you said they fear us so is this like
the atomic bomb of democracy no this is
the way government should work
other questions
Cena thank you uh Ken for uh all your
time and thank everyone else who has uh
stayed through a memorable afternoon we
have a lot of material here and um again
thanks for your time and your travel and
we will have an executive session on
this uh a week from today
and some of you know the process uh
whatever comes out of committee will go
to the Full House in some fashion we
don't know what it'll be yet and then
we'll go from there
uh
thank you
[Applause]
I'd like to thank everybody for being
well behaved